hey Ian yes Tim how would you define
martial law
when the military Authority overrides
civil Authority what does that mean what
does that what does that mean basically
the generals start calling the shots the
general start calling or the commander
the president yeah where do you get the
definition from where that was just off
the top of my head based on what I've
known through video games and and
history and what if the military gets
deployed to enforce special non-civilian
law
is that martial law
wow sounds sounds like it so let's say
they suspend
civilian law impose special laws
and then the military comes to enforce
those 100 that sounds exactly like maybe
that's Marshall yeah according to at
least one uh report that I was reading
from the US government we cited on
timcast.com martial law requires the the
a military commander to assume authority
to create or execute laws and so what's
happening in Australia doesn't
officially count as martial law okay
though many people are saying it is
because the military has been deployed
in Sydney
to enforce the lockdowns and um that's
one way of putting it the other way to
put it is Australia has called in the
military to suppress protests against
the lockdowns it's getting uh hot to say
the least we got a bunch of other news
too I mean on top of that in the United
States there's talk of uh vaccine
mandates for federal employees now I
believe the firefighters Union is saying
no to this the postal workers union is
saying no to this the uh there's talk
about maybe a national mandate in
general and now the White House is
pushing back saying no no we're not
going to do that it's not going to
happen the New York Times has come out
with a story saying vaccinated people
can spread the the Delta variant just as
easily as unvaccinated people which has
sparked a major controversy as the White
House and other officials are claiming
the New York Times is fake news and
they're publishing misinformation and
then the Washington Post publish
something similar so hey YouTube I don't
know what's true anymore so I'll just
say whatever YouTube says in their
official rules is the truth and talk to
your doctor well we'll talk about this
and we'll talk about what's happening in
the political landscape what's going on
with this in these other countries and
we're being joined by professor of
political science Wilford Riley great to
be here guys wildebeest roof
do you want to just briefly uh just uh
introduce yourself yeah I'm I'm Wilfred
Riley I'm an associate professor of
political science at Kentucky State
University I'm probably a bit better
known as the author of the books hate
crime hoax and taboo and I'm glad to be
here live with you guys tonight right on
I'm pretty sure I've cited your book and
some of your writings before on you know
talking about hate crime hopes hoaxes
and things like that so A good logical
move yeah absolutely absolutely that's
why we're you're here and and we'll talk
about a lot of what's going on of course
I just asked Ian a question he's sitting
here that was exciting that was exciting
that intro there yeah how would you
define martial law
um I think that the simplest definition
because you're going back in political
science over different sorts of
civilization would be the military
taking over day-to-day Administration
deciding whether or not you get to do
regular ordinary things I mean uh
definitely some of the covet policy in
for example Australia I mean is
approaching that level where you see I
mean you know tanks moving around in the
streets to prevent people from coming
outside and that sort of thing so it's a
flexible definition it also it I could
get into some really eye-glazing Wonka
right here like it depends on the legal
code in each one of those countries but
uh in essence the the law that governs
the military what's in that green book
they give you in the Army governed the
civilians the Army's running the country
there is though in the U.S it's a they
say civilians will not be tried in
military tribunals or military courts so
it's basically just at least as the U.S
U.S defines it or has in the past
Commander takes over asserts nearly
supreme authority and civilian law
suspended well we'll get into we'll get
into all that stuff Ian well oh yeah
yeah well hello thank you yeah Lydia's
pressing all the buttons I am also
corner I'm very excited for tonight's
guest he is exceedingly eloquent and I'm
really looking forward to what he has to
say so Professor everyone yeah I'm
excited
before we get started head over to
timcast.com
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member and you'll
get access access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
as well as an advertisement free
experience on the website and that's
because we're ad supported and we're
also member supported so if you want to
support our Fierce and independent
journalists who write these stories
break these things down try to figure
out what the truth is then become a
member or I mean just share the Articles
you like because like I mentioned we
have ads too that help support our work
and keeps the keeps the lights on and
keeps more and more journalists are
coming in let's talk about this first
story we got here oh wait wait I'm sorry
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
there we go there we go yeah all right
here's the first story we got from
timcast.com Australia sends their
military to enforce coronavirus
lockdowns in Sydney NPR reports the
military's help is needed to enforce the
restrictions because a small minority of
people thought the rules didn't apply to
them New South Wales police Minister
David Elliott told Australia's Channel
9. Australian prime minister Scott
Morrison has come in for heavy criticism
in recent weeks over the slow pace of
vaccinations in Australia where about 14
percent have been fully dosed one of the
poorest records among any member country
of the organization for economic
cooperation and development so when they
say a small minority thinks the rules
don't apply to them did they mean by
that 86 percent because that doesn't
sound like a small minority to me now
here's the fascinating part of course
they're bringing in the military
Morrison said if you get vaccinated
there will be special rules that apply
to you why because if you're vaccinated
you present less of a public health risk
you are less likely to get the virus you
are less likely to transmit it the Prime
Minister told reporters on Friday
according to the Sydney Morning Herald
well now according to the New York Times
the and the Washington Post and the
Daily Mail and many other outlets you
are not less likely to transmitted so I
I don't know that's what they said I'm
not going to say they're right I don't
know what YouTube's rules are all
they're all crazy I will point this out
though you may have noticed in the past
week there were crazy protests you see
these there's crazy protests all over
Sydney thousands of people were in the
streets in Sydney and like London
yeah
um this is not about a small minority of
people that are defying this is about
thousands of people in the streets chaos
erupts in Sydney as anti-lockdown
protesters clash with police there was
another story that said basically the
same thing chaos in Sydney because
regular people were going on with their
lives as though there was no lockdowns
yeah people just continue to do their
thing how much so what did they do
deploy the military
yeah I mean so first of all I think
there's a lot of competition in in this
race in these Lanes but Australia seems
to have had one of the craziest
reactions to covid-19 of any major State
I mean I don't ever want to give
incorrect figures but the the day over
day rolling death average there is it's
below nine I know that it's an extremely
extraordinary way lower yeah it could it
could be that that's the most liberal
estimate I've ever heard sort of past
year the vaccine is available the thing
with covid-19 is that not everyone is at
equal risk from covet 19. I mean that
that's mundane as hell but it Bears
repeating I mean Tim you pointed this
out to me before the show I mean the
total number of people under 40 that
have died from kovid it would nine
thousand or something like that it's
like it's like nine thousand seven
hundred and something I don't have the
full numbers but it's yeah the nine
thousands yeah the total number of
individuals under 18 at least in the USA
because we keep hearing about the
children that have died from or with
covid-19 is under 600 it's 331 yeah
that's a population of 75 million so I
mean the the question with Australia is
have they gotten most of their seniors
and their very vulnerable people
vaccinated I happen to know they have I
mean that's where they targeted that
first chunk of vaccine that got up to
around 15 of the population so the
question is can you keep healthy younger
people that are mostly at very low risk
of death frankly from covid-19 or even
hospitalization at home for months and
years at a time to prevent nine deaths a
week or whatever not I guess it Max that
number per day in a country the size of
California Texas I would say no I mean
that seems utterly bizarre in terms of
how we look at Liberty there's a well do
they have any there a lot of people are
making the joke that's like ah former
penal colony haha okay well you know
perhaps I guess you know I was thinking
about this and maybe there is something
to that we as Americans fought for our
independence to Win It people in
Australia it was part of you know I
don't know the full history of Australia
yeah but you know penal Conley I don't
know their full the numbers for
Australia I can only really speak to the
U.S but I will say that there was there
was this viral video that was um
I just put crazy and hilarious I suppose
it's a news report of Australia where
they're like one person has been
infected oh yeah we'll be locking down
for the next month and it's like wait
what it's like wow people have gone gone
really over the top with this stuff I
tell you I see some of these stories and
I'm like if there was anything if I was
if I was trying to advise any of these
people to like discourage vaccination
I'd keep doing what you're doing that's
this is a great no they're they're
trying to get people to get the vaccine
but they're just doing basically the
opposite you think when you have 14 of
your population getting vaccinated
sending in the military is going to make
them think you have the best their best
interest at heart the opposite because
you go this route
there's no turning back now you have
dedicated yourself to authoritarianism
you have sacrificed your trust and
credibility where can you go after that
well I mean you can go some ugly places
but actually this is to me by far the
most disturbing thing about coven 19. I
mean the the things that the citizenry
has allowed to be kind of placed on the
table
um so even before the vaccination I mean
in in the USA something like 2.8 to 3.1
million people die every year I mean
that's that's damned close to 10 000 a
day it's eight or nine thousand so even
at the peak of covid-19 I had no
objection at that time to wearing a mask
I actually got one that works which most
people didn't but you're not seeing a
devastating world-ending plague like
even at the peak of covid-19 there's no
evidence really if you look at like the
West the Western European studies the
major pieces that were actually
published in journals that lockdowns
worked better than sort of well done in
pi you know stay home if you feel sick
quarantine the sick clean your body that
kind of thing but now with the vaccine
out and in most of these countries
including Australia the truly vulnerable
vaccinated you're seeing these utterly
bizarre moves like you're what you
described as a factual situation there
was one infection and correct me if I'm
wrong but that wasn't a death that
wasn't I don't know a whole new story
they're talking about just like some
viral video where they mentioned if
someone got sick and I think he was
Hospital lives but they're not dead and
they're not going to be and so they
locked down 900 000 people that's New
South Wales I mean that's a that's a
region that's roughly comparable to one
of the Dakotas it's a huge State decent
number of people in it
um I think if this is possible in
reaction to that level of risk like one
let's say death means 900 000
incarcerations for three months it would
be very very difficult for these Western
societies to do anything functional
going forward not even the stereotypical
war with China but what are we going to
do about climate change like this this
stuff's not off the table like I foresee
climate lockdowns being a very real
possibility they've already talked about
masks next flu season and at some point
people are just going to have to say no
I'm going to vote for the conservative
party or even even the Libertarians or
whatever is necessary to crazy stuff but
whatever whatever's necessary to kind of
get this
you should not stop living your life
because someone else might die that way
lies a society with no cars you know
someone down the line some people do
think this is the climate lockdown we
saw very early on after a couple weeks
the lockdown New York Times posted that
story saying the Earth is healing and
people started talking they're a bunch
of a bunch of Articles emerged about
pollution and everything clearing up and
then a lot of people said they're
probably exploding the crisis because
they have the climate change agenda
but then you know I I wonder
first you know I'll say this I don't
trust the powerful political
establishment and Elite they they claim
climate change is a disaster but they
buy beachfront property and things like
that so part of me wonders though we
talked about this the other night with
windshield the windshield phenomenon
have you ever heard of that uh no no I
haven't frankly people have started to
notice that when they drive their cars
there's less insects than there used to
be and so it's called the windshield
phenomenon and they've done studies
where they found like an 80 reduction in
uh over over from 2017 to 2021. I think
that's those are the dates yeah they
found a reduction of 80 in insect
populations hitting windshields and a
lot of people think that what you can
get grants for in science by the way is
absolutely amazing bro I mean that
that's got to be at least a million
dollar project sorry well sure sure a
waste of money uh and and not not a
waste of waste of money in terms of
doing the study though but you know they
wasted money when they did the study so
for sure how much money do you need to
drive the car back and forth for four
years a million dollars because we're
gonna hire someone to drive
do this driving in Barbados home of the
next American you know etymological
Association conference right right right
yeah yeah but but isn't there something
that's scary to that and uh you know
that's what I'm worried about what if
what if there is an ecological collapse
and that's why they're they're actually
locking everything down I mean would we
want to just
you know eat and fart ourselves to death
like like yeast in a bottle or would we
need some collective action to Stave
something off or the worst are there
ideologues who believe a doomsday
scenario who have seized the Reigns of
power and are imposing their cult-like
ideology over everybody else
that's a that's a fascinating uh bit of
a bit of a leading question there's
something we're both skeptical about you
know leadership around the world but I
in reality so there are a couple
different elements to this first of all
I am not a conspiracy theorist because I
think most people are stupid I mean
we're both from Chicago I believe both
from that South Side area oh yeah where
am I um I was born in the Bridgeport
area of the city oh okay I moved uh
North to Wicker Park pre-gentrification
I went to St Mary's uh oh well yeah
Midway yeah yeah yeah and I lived in uh
Bridgeport for a little bit but by
Comiskey right or by U.S Cellular Field
yeah that's right down there that's all
that that's White Sox country that's all
right I have family and
um that whole like Chatham uh
Bronzeville that whole area sort of
black and Irish in uh south side of
Chicago that's right now I like I said I
personally claim the north side I went
to I was in Wicker since I was like a
little kid I moved to I still have a
house in East Aurora like the
traditional sort of Latino and Eastern
European area that City so another blue
collar area right nearby an hour away
now but and that's and and and what were
you saying you think people are dumb
yeah well
what are you saying about Chicago now no
that but that that's the point though I
mean like even watching people I knew in
high school try to sell Coke in Little
Italy or east Aurora or something I mean
yeah the percentage of those guys who
went to jail is like 65. I don't think
that there are actually functional
behind the scenes cabals where you have
one Arab guy one Nigerian guy one french
guy two Americans and a Brit that are
secretly trying to control the economy
of the world or something like that I
think I do think you have groups I mean
many of the things that people say in
sort of conspiratorial conversations
like skull and bones at Yale or
Bilderberg Group actually exist you have
groups of rich people that clash with
one another and pursue different agendas
just like you have groups of upper
middle class people that do this or
media individuals but I do think like
first there was a weird sort of climate
porn that you saw in the mainstream
media for a while where you'd see these
headlines like whales have been spotted
in such and such a canal it's like
that's because there are any goddamn
people like you just give them language
but they're taking all the the ships out
of the normal shipping lanes people are
on lockdown that's not a positive of the
the best of these articles either from
covid or within the couple of years
before was the guardian why Genghis Khan
was good for the environment yeah
because he killed so many people you see
that the smoke from the cook fire
stopped the planet called oh there are
some other people that would like to
make those claims about
um I think I think so
well I think that today I don't think
there's a conscious attempt to usher in
a climate lockdown because of covid but
last sentence kind of getting to the
point here on my end I think that
the bigger issue is that the people that
are running a lot of American discourse
have the same solutions to everything
this is so if you notice the climate
Solutions like we need to pursue a more
socialist generous policy of XYZ are the
same as the covet Solutions and the same
as the proposed solution to our race
crisis so I I don't think the issue is
so much what the key that opens the door
is it's kind of what comes through like
all of these things are being used by
people that want the same agenda to a
certain extent yeah it's a it's a
standalone complex we often say it's
it's not a conspiracy it's a bunch of
people of similar ideology working in a
similar Direction because they believe
similar things and but when you look at
the Pareto distribution of you know
basically almost everything in existence
you get the extremes at the very top and
at the very bottom but these extreme
wealthophile powerful people maybe this
is see I don't have any data to back
this up except that you know you look at
sociologically there are times when the
very very few will will coagulate at the
top and I wonder if there are a small
group of people that have been
organizing this since I mean if you look
at the way the Federal Reserve was built
by like eight guys yeah Jekyll Island
that was crazy creepy story
true but I think the issue of the
creature from Jekyll Island right I
think the issue with that though is that
well at the simplest level in political
science about half of the rich disagree
with the other half I mean that's that's
why there's this extraordinary kind of
back and forth of like your well you're
funded by the Koch brothers well you're
funded by George Soros and the Sciences
I mean you have the Chinese billionaires
that unexpectedly are kind of coming in
often on the right side of things
politically yeah I mean on the other
hand you have uh the the moonmen these
Tech Bros that are currently flying
around in space so I I don't think
there's one unified position that people
are advancing across say great wealth to
try to move the world forward I think
that there are some positions that are
more influential than others because one
group of sort of coastal upper middle
class Urban big city mostly leftists
happens to control the media social
media and Academia in the USA and
Britain in particular so there are ideas
you see more often than you see other
ideas and I think that that is that the
climate Panic is one of those but I
don't think in practice a governor
DeSantis or somebody's necessarily going
to back that actually happening or the
billionaires in that state are going to
you're familiar with the journal lists
have you ever hear of those not
journalist a journal like journ Dash o
dash list it was a list it was it was a
web list of journalists that all
communicate with each other oh yeah yeah
this is this is this is a good example
of I guess I don't know it borders on
conspiracy in a sense in that they would
all share stories and then agree on them
because they're all in the same chat and
then all of these Outlets would publish
the same stories well to clarify I don't
think conspiracies don't exist actually
to talk to kind of the audience for a
second if you don't think there are
wealthy powerful people behind the
scenes that sometimes collab together to
do things that would get you arrested
you're a fool I mean like even at my
little level like I'm pretty I'm a
member like the lower upper class and
I'm often contacted by friends from the
U of I law for example or you know
Freedom Fest which I just attended great
event but reasonable pretty high level
stuff media figures do you want to work
on this
um let's keep this low key for now we're
gonna we're gonna trip them from behind
with this one and I would only imagine
what Prince Harry's inbox looks like so
of course they're conspiracies in that
sense the question I guess really is
just when it crosses the line to the
crazy scenarios a lot of the left and
the hard right seem to believe in so
like for example my email list right now
is I think 8 000 people nothing crazy
but eight thousand most of them are
journalists of some kind they're mostly
on the center right I'm pretty sure I
could create a story if I happen to find
out some piece of information about a
crooked politician the
the only reason that's annoying when you
look at the journal list or a lot of the
I mean there are whole like jobs that
are left is still up on Google where
they advertise all these left-leaning
activist jobs and it's one network of
people many of whom don't admit they're
left-leaning activist so the issue with
that I think is the pretense of
neutrality right so if there's anybody
from say CNN or NPR on on the message
Lister that that's very ethically
problematic I think both you and I would
say like I'm heterodox maybe Center
center right politically I think the
government's a bunch of scumbags like I
have the set group of opinions pretty
open about them if you say I'm a neutral
reporter for NBC and you are taking
talking points from you know Junior
operative at the DNC that you're
sleeping with who's the person ahead of
you on the journal list oh my no but I
mean you're talking about a real person
there uh no of course not a gentleman
would not say such a thing but I mean
like if you and that actually is I have
someone in mind but they don't work at
NBC and it's not particularly wrong
about maybe but anyway but anyway like
the the point of all this is that if you
go on the air and you're saying this BS
this goes for the right as well like all
these guys talking about Chastity until
marriage is critically important lock
the door Javier you know like if you're
doing that there's a significant ethical
issue with that I think that's really
the only point there are many
conspiracies behind the scenes
journalists have opinions and you know I
I used to think that we would try to
have journalists keep their opinions to
themselves so they could just do the job
and and not cause Strife but I I think
that that era is is long since passed
you know because the difference in
opinions now is is fundamental world
view where someone's opinion is
literally them saying I support the
Constitution and someone else's opinion
saying I oppose it and I'm like well
hold on there a minute like we've got a
very very distinct difference of world
view on this there it used to be a
journalist could say something well of
course I support the United States and
the Constitution that was not
controversial now it is so now if you if
you came out and said I believe America
should enforce its immigration laws your
right wing bye-bye that's one of one of
the ways they've tried accusing me of
being a conservative is that they're
like Tim Poole has defended conservative
claims about immigration in the United
States I'm like what is that what does
that mean Bernie Sanders was pro-border
barrier in 2008 and in 2015 he said no
open borders just because he went
farther left doesn't mean I moved but
that's where we're at I mean you you can
literally just say something innocuous
and it's literally conservative because
the left has become so extreme and
revolutionary I suppose yeah and I also
think this moves in Cycles I mean like
I'm A hip-hop kid and I remember the
moral majority in the 1980s although
Tipper Gore was part of this but like
chasing rappers and hard rockers through
the halls of Congress you know asking
two Live Crew what a coach was like just
this this ridiculous embarrassing crap I
mean just you know and so that sort of
thing like had they gotten their way we
wouldn't be talking about parental
warning labels on rapper Rock CDs we'd
be talking or I mean imagine EDM Cruella
and all that you'd be talking about that
not being available on the market like
get it wet would be available only as
like a download from some pirate site
same with a DMX or Jay-Z album so that
that was the right overextending and I
think we've definitely seen the pendulum
swing back into complete lunacy this is
one of the things that I noticed a lot
when I wrote taboo specifically because
some of it was intended to be edgy like
oh let's take on the alt ride let's take
on BLM but like the immigration chapter
I thought was just completely neutral
like at one point I think my description
was we should let in
sane reasonably able-bodied non-criminal
immigrants capable of getting jobs which
might involve some kind of basic IQ or
aptitude test it's like well wouldn't it
and people started describing this as
sort of a far-right proposal like during
an interview someone asked me if I would
let in disabled women with AIDS and I
said I mean I kind of danced around the
question but it was just sort of I
wouldn't prioritize that as an
immigration policy let's say like
there's an element of a moral common
sense that you kind of need to exist as
a healthy adult and I think to some
extent we need to get back to let's say
morally rational shared common sense
like the country's flawed but if you
openly fight against it we're not going
to say that you're the highest form of
patriot this this is one of the biggest
problems we have right now
a far right in the colloquial sense
opinion on immigration would be shut
down oh actually I think it's
repatriated repatriation of the right
word so you actually see these opinions
on the internet where people who are all
the time yeah they're like send them
back like but they live here it's like
don't care it's like okay that is weird
like they moved here they got
citizenship and you're like nope cut it
on all right then you've got a
right-wing opinion of we should you know
a further right we should lock down the
borders no more immigration then you've
got the right we should have sound
immigration policy and then you have
like the center right where it's like
well we're okay with with refugees and
asylees then you have the center where
it's like a similar position you get
start moving to the left and they're
like open up the borders increase the
numbers if you if you entertain the
Centrist position of
um like my position literally where they
claim it's conservative is I think we
should allow uh legal asylees refugees
refugees to come into this country and
we should help them uh there should
obviously be some limit so we don't get
exploited like people people who might
come from Africa to Brazil and then try
and come here that's a lot of questions
got questions about that but Cuba and
Mexico like Yeah by all means let's
figure this one out
that's conservative well I mean I I do
think you need to get into some of the
technical definitions like I I don't
necessarily think without mocking your
position that you'd be an asylum Seeker
from Mexico in any kind of real
political sense like a lot of the
countries this was one of the things
that struck me because I took some time
off from standard academic writing while
I was working on the books and like
coming back into this debate people are
starting to use the term Asylum Seeker
for immigrants migrant yeah but people
coming from countries like in terms of a
lot of the groups in Chicago Mexico
Poland Guatemala Guatemala actually
would be one of the Central American
countries we're supposed to feel the
most sort of heart Wren for uh Honduras
Brazil Costa Rica Costa Rica is a
pleasant country it's amazing it's a
great place it's where they filmed
Jurassic Park great food I mean it's
just but the idea that someone who's a
Tico from Costa Rica is a refugee is
absurd I mean right right right but so I
mean it's just but that that's what I
mean like I'm talking about let's say
there's somebody who lives in a border
City in in Mexico and they run a foul of
some gangs or something and then they're
like what do I do and so they jump you
know they go to the Border they go and
say they're coming for me what do I do
okay well that person we don't die I
mean it'd be if someone came in the
house screaming and panting and
threatened it's like help call the
police I'd call the police but that's
that's that's not the majority so well
it's like what you said the leftist
started calling all of them that's why I
Lisa refugees AOC did it legal asylees
have broken no law and then Homan was
like yeah they did they violated this a
lot of things and he reads it off yeah
so there are certain circumstances where
I can absolutely understand like if a
guy's being chased and he runs through
the river or whatever to escape it's
like all right well you know I don't
know what to say to that guy like get
safe you know what I mean but what we're
seeing is people from Africa flying to
Brazil traveling up through South
America to the U.S border we're saying
people from the South American countries
moving up coming to America I'm like
dude they're economic migrants yeah they
get turned away well I mean I think the
the first one is actually not anymore
the first question in response to even
kind of the moral component of that
would be like if I grew up in Baltimore
do I have the right to seek asylum in
Japan that's what I'm talking about no
yeah I mean it's there's an element of
so like looking at this point by Point
as a political scientist like if you're
in Mexico first of all if you're in
Mexico and you're engaged in a violent
gunfight with the cartels you're very
unlikely to be a taxpayer I mean like
the old American Mafia like you're there
are some brutal abuses of women and so
on in coyote roles but it's very
unlikely that the cartels and say a
group of policemen are without any
negotiations gonna challenge each other
the kind of fighting that requires one
of the policemen to flee here if that
happens sure I mean the border cities of
Mexico are extremely violent this show
it's all the time yeah well there I mean
there's two dots in American cities too
actually we have I mean like Baltimore
has a higher crime rate than most of the
cities on the border I guess what I'm
saying is most of those shootouts
involve the equivalent of gang violence
right um but I mean so at risk of being
like thought cold there are a bunch of
solutions here like first you can move
within Mexico Mexico actually has as
funds that are dedicated to helping
people get away from gang and cartel
Warfare as we do by the way I mean we
have massive witness relocation programs
and so on so I mean I think that would
be my first uh step if I were a Mexican
Citizen and Patriot that was having this
problem I mean at the another level like
we could let people into the country
that could document this
um and I mean I improved version of a
polygraph test like there'd have to be
something almost unpleasant to go
through but there'd have to be a period
during which you could stay in the
country you could have for example a
one-year protective Visa if you're not a
traditional Refugee people forget this
by the way refugees and TPS recipients
are supposed to go back when the crisis
is over so I think a lot of this stuff
on the left becomes the endless
extension of compassion
where you see people that were displaced
by for example that awful earthquake in
Haiti which is a legitimately terrible
thing but 15 years later are still in
the USA and are not oppressed I mean
many of the not necessarily Haiti but
many of like the black Caribbean States
or Island paradises I mean Bermuda
Bahamas Barbados I mean they have
incomes on part the USA so guys would be
here running stores and things of that
nature like I appreciate anyone's desire
to hustle and get a better life but
that's the same explanation people give
for selling weed like if you come here
from Mexico or Bahamas in 99 of cases
you're not unacilee that's a far right
opinion though yeah anyway okay far
right on this issue like almost everyone
I mean I mean like media wise like I'm
not literally I don't know what I'm
saying like Simply Having a position
where you're like hey how does this make
sense I think it has a lot to do with
I guess tribal psychosis that there that
people are so desperate to climb their
claw their way to the top of the social
order on the left that they're
constantly one-upping their opinions and
accusing the other people of being
impure so you get some person who like
10 years ago was on the left and like I
agree with Bernie Sanders
well by that standard today you are a
far right you know individual you're a
you're a nationalist you're evil or all
the really awful words they'll use for
you
how how are we supposed to have a
functioning political ecosystem if one
side has no moral system or framework or
principles and it's just I'm gonna say
the most extreme extreme thing possible
that moves me further and further in One
Direction one of the things that I think
actually is that there are almost no
people that actually believe this stuff
I I think you see the massive influence
of again the lower upper class Coastal
Urban very specific mostly white liberal
block on sites like Twitter and insta I
mean so they're obviously that famous
piece came out I think wired that found
out that what was it 15 of Americans are
on Twitter at all and like 20 20
um what is I think it's 22 of Americans
are on Twitter at all
yeah and it's like a smaller percentage
ten percent are responsible for
something like 80 of the viral tweets so
you've got let's say 2.2 2.3 percent of
the population that's driving this
discourse and a lot of it it's very
disproportionately first of all until
pretty reasonable it was also very
disproportionately annoying all right uh
Pepes and groupers and so on all they
cut out some of them but they haven't
cut out their opponents so I mean
extremely sjw heavy a lot of a lot of
tras a lot of trans rights activists so
on a lot of positions that almost don't
exist in mainstream America and I think
it's important to keep that distinction
up like these people influence the
discourse that goes into kind of yeah
mid-level journalism like if you're on
Twitter and you have more than 10 000
followers you're very likely to also
contribute articles from time to time to
say Jezebel or something like that no
particular hate for them so you have a
lot of this scene in like Urban Youth
life and it seems like it's very
prevalent but if you ask people like
should immigrants be able to read or
something like that like you'd see a
massive massive yes versus no in America
let's say you've got a hundred cities
with a hundred people in each City in
each city is one socialist whenever this
election whenever there's an election
the Socialist vote socialist and it
accounts for one percent of the vote and
everyone ignores it then Along Comes the
internet and now you have a city-sized
socialist Community online because all
the one socialist from each of the
hundred cities now forms a massive
community on Twitter where it seems like
wow look at all of these police these
people it's like the size of New York is
the size of a city and then you're like
oh it's just one person in their bedroom
in these different places the problem is
it really does have an impact look at
these these social these uh big Brands
will get harassed by this community and
then they'll issue a public statement on
TV to tens of millions of people about
how they now agree with this Fringe
belief and they apologize for not seeing
it sooner and the problem is it is true
very few people use Twitter but Twitter
does have influence hilariously it's
stupid and regular people don't speak up
so you'll be ruled by that two percent
well unless we start speaking up I mean
and what you see like I mean your
platform obviously is on par like I
looked at the ratings for most of the
major
um Prime Time cable news shows on MSNBC
and CNN the other day I actually posted
this to Twitter and most of them get
less engagement than I do on Twitter
um I think Don Lemon uh was at 570
000 engagements either per day or per
week it must be per day it must be but I
mean and scrolling up all the way up to
Tucker Carlson was like three million a
day but the simple reality is that most
of the temcast interviews I've looked at
have a million a million and a half
views I think that when people start
talking and saying things that are
obviously true that kind of break The
Gaslight you'll find that the other 98
of people want to listen to them and
that's why there's there's this
fanatical attempt to do two things one
is to label people in the most
ridiculous way possible like Joe Rogan
or Jimmy Dore as Nazis and in reality
these are cats that are all across the
Spectrum Matt taibi and I actually one
of the first times I was on Twitter was
arguing about bs for a while because
he's I don't even know if he remembers
but he's significantly on the left
absolutely Glenn Glenn Greenwell the
other great journalists but I mean it's
Barry Weiss who's the editor of the New
York Times like a week ago I mean so but
the first argument is like Barry White
is Glenn Greenwald what the hell do they
know about journalism just a bunch of
all right Nazis it's this attempt to
kind of just Shuffle foot off the stage
and pretend nothing happened but the
second and more troubling aspect of this
is the attempt by conventional media to
take the actual internet kids off of
social media and replace them with kind
of Triple A versions of conventional
media shows that's very definitely
something happening when I look at
YouTube you see suggestions from CNN on
the sidebars so this is what I was going
to bring up I can pull up the the
ratings Thursday for all these different
cable channels and in the key
demographic 25 to 54 CNN loses easily to
Tim cast IRL
however when you take into account all
of their their viewers you've got you
know uh 8 P.M uh Anderson Cooper with
774 000 you've got Cuomo with 861 000.
Don Lemon with 716 000. and so
they're doing really well among a lot
older people which says a lot about what
will happen with shows like this moving
forward perhaps people will age out and
you know then CNN will become less and
less relevant and more people watch
shows like this but the one thing you
need to understand is that I can sit
here and say look how great this show is
look how many viewers we get because
their TV ratings are in the gutter and
then YouTube puts CNN on the front page
they put MSNBC on the front page and CNN
gets something like 150 million views
per month relative to our 20. so we may
be beating them on TV but YouTube is
mandating viewership of their trash and
it's funny when you see their videos all
thumbs down everybody hates it it
doesn't work for the platform nobody
like no it doesn't work for What YouTube
is you can't put TV on YouTube and think
it'll work
yeah no I but I think that this is kind
of like the old Russian division between
Pravda and samasda I mean so there are
150 million views of CNN perhaps on a
daily basis if you're counting YouTube's
fronts piece and I'm sure perhaps
airport lounges and so on but how many
of those people are actually watching
CNN and absorbing political content from
them and taking it seriously I I I'll
stop real quick sorry 98 million so
CNN's down substantially that's like
half from where they were a few months
ago okay all right well and that that's
a monthly basis figure yeah 98 million
uh views for the CNN YouTube in the past
month not to mention CNN does have
network channels as well so all the
peripheral YouTube channels you know
they get their views as well they gain
100 000 subscribers per month I mean we
get like ten thousand my Twitter and uh
YouTube engagement last month it was if
I recall correctly 34 million that was
mostly due to our RTS from larger
accounts but I mean
I don't mean to mock at all I'm loving
the undisclosed location great group of
guys to talk to but I mean we're both
kind of guys with computers so I mean
when you say like okay well CNN is 10
you know 10 in the lead over me and 80
the lead over you Riley like both of us
can just go home and make another video
on our laptops like they're spending
millions of dollars to produce this crap
that barely beats out and there's so
many other people in that in that space
I mean from Ben Shapiro to Clara Layman
and Brett Weinstein on the other side of
that to but
um uh reaction from leads to one of
those but I mean to obviously Joe Rogan
you know Adam Carolla I mean all these
people aren't the same Larry Elder on
kind of the black right but many of
these content producers are outpacing
the major shows on network news and all
you have to do is go upstairs and talk
into your computer I mean one of my most
watched videos again mine in general
aren't that alone aren't at that million
hit range it was like me talking to my
phone I mean so anyone now can become
given any reasonable amount of training
and honor but can become a journalistic
resource so I that's what the mass media
is terrified of last last comment here
they're not taking quote unquote
conservatives offline because you and
Jimmy Durant's on aren't conservatives
in the first place they're taking
threats offline right so like the one
time I'm center right personally but I
tried to look at this honestly once and
like that month the majority of the
people D platform like Chapo Trap House
you owe blacks trillions like the funny
reparations page cop blot one of the
oldest libertarian party accounts on
YouTube or what this was I believe on
Twitter it was on Twitter Reddit and in
most cases YouTube that's when they took
Chapo trap off Reddit but I mean like
Chapo trap house is to say the least not
a conservative site but it was becoming
a threat to the media the Dirtbag left
bran and the Dirtbag left hoodies and
the jokes and this you know comments
about the CIA probably didn't help out
so they ain't there anymore but it's not
just a conservative liberal thing it's a
threats thing yeah I mean mean the Jabo
still still exists they're the number
two uh most subscribed to uh patreon
okay I'm glad you're here so yeah so
they're they're they're still you know
prominent I I don't know what they're
it's interesting there's like a a weird
the the podcast ecosystem it's it's hard
to actually track it's very different
from TV with TV we look at the ratings
we know what's going on with podcasting
I mean our biggest platform is YouTube
we get a decent amount we get the 80 70
70 or 80 of our our podcast views or
lessons or whatever on YouTube and then
we do decently well on uh on iTunes and
Spotify I think we are a top 250 on
iTunes uh there was a period where like
my main show was actually really high up
because I was working every single day
we took that down but you can actually
track who's successful like I don't even
know where chat with Trap House
registers on this I know they have a lot
of Die Hard fans but they might have 36
000 people who are paying to get their
special content but that might be the
everyone who watches their show or it
could be substantially more I don't know
when you look at TV nobody pays for that
for the most part I mean some people
might pay for a cable package but CNN is
effectively given to you like they make
you watch it you know what I mean like
you mentioned airports yeah State media
it's the literally the media a program
that runs in the airports that are
funded by branches of debt they canceled
that the CNN airport is gone gone but
probably still hotel lobbies I guess are
we going to see like Fox airport it
would actually be really funny to see
Newsmax airport yeah they should go for
it not really getting more or less
reliable than MSNBC but like I'd like
I'd like to see it for a couple months
try it out that's my favorite thing
about the media well I'm gonna tell you
about Biden it's this guy's screaming I
love it when they're like oin is is a
conspiracy site and it's like bro did
you do you watch your own channel like
have you seen the things you've said
about Russia no these people uh they're
they're they're something special
actually I want to I want to pull this
up I want to pull up uh some no no not
this one where's the other one okay
we're gonna pull up this one we're gonna
start with this story here I got I got
to do this oh
I got a special uh uh disdain for big
Tech social media so this is something
that's been going around for a while
there is a link to the cdc.gov all right
it is the cdc's website if you post this
link Facebook will flag it as fake news
Facebook because they've given the
ability to third-party fact Checkers who
are crackpot Wingnut conspiracy
theorists have labeled the CDC as fake
news here it is here it is right look at
this this is a post from Facebook that I
posted the the website is cdc.gov C
cells DLS Locs 2021 721 2022 lab alert
changes CDC RT PCR SARS
covet2testing1.html there you go now
there's some other stuff in there if you
want to actually get the link the link
is just them saying they're encouraging
uh sites to update their PCR tests to uh
better tests
a third-party fact Checker flagged it as
fake news and so a bunch of people have
done this and it shows you the extent to
which the media is broken who in their
right mind was given the authority to
flag the CDC as fake news I uh what am I
supposed to say on YouTube oh YouTube
Don't ban me I don't know Facebook
flagged me that's this this is what
happens when you have a crackpot broken
media
that people just keep saying I trust the
science I believe the media they just
believe whatever they're told until it
just goes full psycho now we're now
we're in this really crazy space
where the news is changing so rapidly
because there's so much contradictory
information coming up and coexisting at
the same time that people are writing
contradictory stories at the same time
so the example I gave the other day
let's say uh fauci comes out and says
You Gotta Wear two masks and the next
day he says no I didn't mean it you
don't gotta wear two masks that that
information changes in the viral
environment have prompted a very
necessary revision of policy by the
leaders at the CDC well no so here's
what happens with these two nearly
concurrent contractory State
contradictory statements
MSNBC might see the statement You Gotta
Wear two masks an hour later fauci says
no no I was mistaken I mean because the
real story is like a day later but let's
say an hour later he says no Fox News
then publishes fauci says not not to
wear two masks MSNBC and fox could
publish those stories at the exact same
time and then the leftists will see
MSNBC the conservative will see Fox News
and then they'll both be at a bar and be
like why are you wearing two masks why
aren't you wearing two masks my story
says my story says information overload
it's too quick and people can't figure
out what's the latest and newest
information now it's come to the White
House where we have the story from the
New York Times check this out the New
York Times says breaking news the Delta
variant is as contagious as chickenpox
and may be spread by vaccinated people
as easily as the unvaccinated and
internal CDC report said but then we get
this guy Ben wakana in all caps
vaccinated people do not transmit the
virus at the same race on vaccinated
people and if you fail to include that
context you're doing it wrong and then
people are like who do I trust the
government
or the New York Times
well now someone could write an article
citing Ben saying the claim is not true
then someone could write something
claiming for the New York Times this
this is true and now we have political
factions choosing which one they think
makes more sense instead of knowing who
to trust
yeah I think that's absolutely correct
um the one piece of advice I will give
to an intelligent young audience would
be go check for yourself I mean you can
go to the CDC website and see what their
data actually is and whether the times
reported on it honestly Nobody Does that
yeah everybody should for a lot of the
things I report like the National Crime
rate for example where there's this huge
argument which I've never understood but
big back and forth on the internet
between like black guys working class
white guys you know Arab guys who might
be suspected of terrorism someone like
who commits the most crime you can find
out like the government publishes the
crime stats every year uh well if you if
you tweet those crime stats you'll be
banned not really actually I've done it
a bunch of times it's not something I've
ever seen flagged anywhere oh yeah um
there was uh who was it was it Tommy
Robinson I think in the UK oh okay and
that that makes sense they don't have
any rights well yeah but this is Twitter
Banning him Twitter banned Tommy
Robinson I believe it was Tommy Robinson
and uh Magic Nawaz who is like not a fan
of Tommy defended him saying he
published factual data from you know
crime statistics Twitter does not care
it's a disparaging comment I've seen
that happen once or twice I mean for
example Andy Noe pointed out at one
point that there was no epidemic of
violence against transgender women
um of color yeah the the rate of
violence against transgender people
actually wrote an article about this for
quill at once because one if there
actually is a hate crime epidemic you
want to stop it but two I strongly
suspected that most shooting or stabbing
victims would be young working-class men
about 50 people of color because we know
that because that's the crime data but
anyway so I looked at this and actually
found the rate of violence against
transgender women is lowering the rate
of violence against just men along with
a bunch of other groups blacks poor
whites so on down the line but Andy said
that I think he cited the article and he
said and if you're a trans woman of
color the person most likely to kill you
is black it's not going to be a white
supremacist it's going to be a jilted
lover or something like that and he was
banned for a couple days right but those
are the only two cases I've ever seen I
mean in general if you cite The BJs
crime report like in academic Twitter
that it's extremely widely known that
men have a higher crime rate than women
African-Americans at least before you
adjust for you know age and social class
have a higher when you tweet the racial
component tons of people get banned for
this it's the way you frame it if a
bunch of like in the past if you saw
that it's 60 of the crimes were
committed by black men it doesn't mean
that you're more likely to have that
happen in the future just because that
was the rate of the past doesn't mean
that that's the likelihood of the future
so that I could see could be looked at
as like he phrased it wrong
right but it's just in I get it I don't
want to have a semantic argument
um in terms of what's going on with the
the censorship a better example is Dave
Rubin did you see what Ian what happened
yesterday yeah I got uh two days ago and
what it what did Dave say right from
Twitter no idea honestly so there's a
story from suspension from Twitter who
got suspended so yeah not to interrupt
you but I think this is more on topic
it's all on topic Dave tweeted that in
his opinion we the vaccines aren't doing
what they were promised and now they're
talking about booster shots
okay they are talking about booster
shots uh Dave then when he came back he
cited the source and then there's a
story from the Washington Post where
they say
uh uh the viral load among people who
are vaccinated it's comparable to those
who aren't and that was
surprising to people essentially
confirming what Dave said yeah he had to
spend it on Twitter for saying and and
one of the problems is this is why I
showed this post from I want to pull
this up again from Facebook where they
flagged the CDC as fake news the reason
the CDC got flagged as fake news is
because the data changes so rapidly
and so this story comes out and then
people start citing it and then some
other people cite it in probably
incorrect ways and so they say all right
this link is now off limits but you know
what's crazy the video of fauci saying
not to wear masks from last March 20
from from March of 2020 still up
[Music]
so actually I think that there's a
broader problem here that's being
Illustrated so when I say you know tons
of academics cite this and there's no
there's no risk of removal and you say
well I know a bunch of people some
academics some pundits that have been
removed a bigger issue is the total
unreliable unreliability in BS nature of
all of these social media policies what
accounts for the difference probably
Which single guy at the director level
at highest was looking at that post from
Riley or pool or Reuben or whatever at
that day because when people say things
like Taiwan it's not it's not a director
Junior staffer then no no these are
these are outsourced to uh um uh like
tracking farms in Indiana oh okay yeah
that's these are people who sometimes
don't even speak English I'm not I'm not
a stronger version of the same argument
yeah I've actually talked with people
who uh have done this work with with
Google and and Facebook and things like
that and they say that there will be
someone you know in say India who's
going through the rules and trying to
figure out what's bannable and what
isn't and that's why they have so many
mistakes yeah no I've I've had actually
this same conversation I'm fully
prepared to accept that as true by the
way of just an enhancement of the same
thing when I started teaching cybersec
back in like 2016 17 we had people that
were execs in the tech World talk to
either me or the students to at least
some extent and their comment then was
it's generally like post college junior
staffer types if something is really
controversial like a discussion of child
pornography so the manager in the room
might come take a look at it but one of
the things Whitney right now
huh like we you just said it so now
someone at YouTube probably got a
notification maybe I mean uh well I
think we're it's it's it's it's true
they have a kiosk where they uh so this
is what I'm not gonna name which company
does this or did this but there were
more than one they showed me this the
live streams are very dangerous for any
one of these companies because with a
video that gets uploaded algorithms can
search them to make sure there's not
specific kind of content within that
video so they check for language you get
demonetized and make it instantly banned
with live streams they never know what's
coming next so what a couple of
companies have done is they have
terminals showing hundreds of live
streams at any one moment and they have
people watching the Flickr yeah and they
look for key phrases to be said or words
to be said and then they know when they
see it they pull them over to the side
line them up and then they get the boss
to come in and we've had our chat
suspended before one thing I do want to
say about this though you have had some
of these things happen because you're
extremely well known in the Internet
space big data is a lot stupider than
most people think it is I mean when
people say things things like if you're
on a pirate side and you click on a file
they can figure out your IP address I
mean my IP address is the Starbucks in
Frankfort Kentucky if hypothetically I
would ever commit such an evil sin yeah
but your Mac address too no but it's
that's generally Max stops at the router
use Tor you use you know I mean it Max
stops on almost every route of the
router Starbucks yeah I mean so it's
actually very easy we're both pretty
familiar with computers it's not hard to
spoof this crap I mean at all so I
actually don't think we're disagreeing
here one I think big data is real like
obviously there are probably first of
all they're probably multi-flagged
personalities like Nero back in the day
on Twitter that these boys would love to
take down so I'm pretty sure that like
pool Rogan maybe five or six others
might be on a board with people that are
at that higher level just looking for
mistakes like how did he like for
example I would be very careful to say
transgender women during the show that's
actually what I would say during polite
conversation anyway but I mean it's just
if I were to say something else who
knows you know and we actually as I have
with all large-scale media Tucker Carl
have had we had this conversation before
the show but I don't think in the
majority of cases big data is all that
good I mean you have someone speaking
their second language in Baja lapor
looking at what would it be per person
35 000 accounts on a daily basis or
something so in general there's you have
a contradiction where there's a mass
amount of all of the content we could
describe I mean including actual
accounts for jihadist groups all over
social media but there are also people
that constantly get sanctioned and
punished and so on and it's the same way
the cops know who the bad kids in town
are whatever but the key point is that
lessons nobody knows what the hell the
rules mean it's almost impossible to get
in touch with these companies
um I actually once got so irritated with
Twitter I was trying to fix some problem
with my account that I asked on my
Twitter does anyone know like the actual
address from their initial IPO like the
emails and so on they had to list it's a
good way to get this stuff by the way
yeah and I got it
um so I mean but and I I was uh I worked
in that sales floor trading floor space
for a while we use these tricks all the
time but nobody knows who to talk to
nobody knows what the rules are it's a
problem this is we are entering a new
kind of
what's the right word Neo it's
neofutalistic in a sense there is a
noble class there's the the modern
landed gentry and that is to say a few
things
we were just talking about you know you
can't call YouTube you can't call
Twitter you can't call Google okay uh
well I can because uh this is the way
that the society is starting to function
that you have followers you have
notoriety then all of a sudden you find
out that people are calling you and you
have email addresses in there they're
here for you all of a sudden you find
out that if you get bad service on an
airline and you've got 10 000 followers
well you might get a responsible what's
that you got a hundred thousand
followers oh now you're flying first
class and they're apologizing you got a
million followers and now you're on that
Global concierge list
this is where we're going so for me or
actually for other people
I get I get messages from people and
they say hey yo Tim I had a video get
you know demonetized do you have any
idea like what I can do to get it fixed
and I'm like honestly I don't you can
try tweeting at you know team YouTube
they try to get things sorted and uh
fairly effective for a lot of people
interestingly social media is an easy
way to connect so now we know they're
handling we can send them a message and
they can see it and some of these
channels are moderately large when I get
demonetized I hit up Google I send an
email right away and they say sorry
about that no problem we got you you got
your sorted right away sometimes they go
like we're not giving you this one for
this or that reason when the Alex Jones
episode got taken down so here's here's
the first thing
I hit up Google and I said are there any
people that we have like that are
outright no-nos for YouTube like you
would ban us for Simply Having I said no
and I was like so you know here are the
people we're we would like to have on
the show and they're like absolutely no
problem and then I said okay and then
they take the episode Down
and I ask them why and they say we won't
tell you so I'm like so I have no idea
what we're taking down so it's not not
everything this is what I'm talking
about by the way like right not not but
not but I'm actually talking to them on
the phone I'm on the phone saying you
can't even tell me what we did and
they're like we don't know because the
people who chose this were higher up
than we are we are so it's like it's
it's it's almost like this neofutelist
thing where they they are creating
classes of people the average person you
can have your account maybe will ban you
a lot of the accounts that are getting
banned and getting censored are small
and this is why you don't see it in the
media the left likes to say cancel
culture isn't real because these
celebrities still are rich or something
but we don't realize is that 90 of those
who got suspended and deleted for a
political opinion were someone with 50
followers or 100 followers and now their
IP band they can't get back on the
service and they're like okay whatever I
guess so the lower the the lower class
individuals in terms of the social
hierarchy of the social credit score
whatever they're building will have no
access to Facebook will have no one to
message we'll simply say please and
they'll say bugger you know we don't
care and then the people who have
prominence are are given access it's
it's a combination of they'll look for
you to make sure they're they're they're
you know they're worried about your
social influence but also when it comes
to Facebook
I know people like I know people in the
news industry and they say here's the
email you need Tim don't worry about it
regular people don't have that so now
we're seeing this weird world where
people are desperate to have followers
because it makes them feel like they can
finally get access to systems and be
treated fairly
yeah I will say also when I mentioned
coming from like the sales or trading
floor space there are a whole variety of
platforms I mean back in the day it was
a manta lead 4-1-1 so on Instant
Checkmate works well now where you can
pull up the contacts for the executives
at most companies including some of the
social companies like when we got
genuinely irritated at Twitter we
started I mean I started doing that
um so I mean you can look at IPO filings
you can look at who the listed
Executives online are I mean it's
possible to contact at one point I
called Mark Cuban during a job at the
company Marcus Evans like all that
stuff's easily available like you can if
you do get one number you can call into
the company and just sort of dial off
Seven's the mail room you know I had
this number on a corporate reference for
Jack Dorsey look I don't have a lot of
time to waste here can you tell me what
his number is don't need to sell a
secretary's fine whatever and it works
nine most of the people I've known that
have a similar Financial background
haven't had a lot of issues with these
companies but of course I mean to some
extent this is just saying what you're
saying like yeah you're a stock broker
for 10 years you'd probably get in touch
with them too you know oh again there
there are two levels here one it's
General really not that hard to break
the rules or the law and not get caught
at the most basic level like if your IP
band I mean which is a real thing like
you can just download Tor and your IP
will be Fiji if you have 50 followers on
Twitter it wouldn't be hard to get back
on Twitter and be a troll frankly
um but again the question is should you
have to do that I'd prefer to see when
we talk about politicians potentially
regulating these brands or sparring back
and forth with them one thing that I
would like to see is just a common sense
demand that these rules be Illustrated
what does this mean what is hate speech
what do you mean you can't tell me who
my prohibited guests are this happens
all the time well there's no prohibited
guests but they won't tell me what was
said that got the video flagged again
now we can only make assumptions about
what we think was actually said and so
when I said to them listen we'll we'll
make clips from the show and we'll
remove whatever you said was against the
rules and they said we won't tell you
and I'm like well
what do you want me to do you got to
keep in mind they all have the ability
to ban anyone at any time as per their
terms every social media site has that
in their terms that's got to change it's
time for uh some will will Chamberlain's
got it he's a smart fella yes he knows I
on a date when Dave got suspended he
said Dave should go into a courtroom get
an injunction get his account turn back
right on turn right on I think I think
you're going to see people starting to
do that it's the same thing as there was
an entire
um genre of legal cases in the 80s and
90s as you guys probably know where
people started talking about
non-traditional property like the right
to receive welfare benefits if welfare
happened to be legal in their state and
it's the same thing here like do you
have some right not to have what is what
is David three four million followers
and your financial livelihood taken away
on a whim I'd be interested in seeing
what a judge says about that I mean
there there has to be some element of
Contracting there I mean has he entered
into an advertising deal with YouTube or
Twitter has he ever made them a dollar
because then I mean you have what does
it offer acceptance consideration I mean
Dave Dave just launched a book and they
suspended him I believe it was when his
around the same time his book is coming
out okay I I'll say straight up if this
was the day his book was coming out they
suspended his account that he should
take the first hour of sales uh as soon
as he was able to promote on Twitter
calculate his losses based on the 12
hours and then say those are the damages
because he would have been able to say
hey my pre-order is available now here's
my new book tweet they suspended him and
he didn't violate any rules they claimed
he did and not only that I think Dave
should file a defamation suit because
they claimed that he put up medical
misinformation but Dave was citing The
Washington Post and I think it was Click
Orlando I'm not sure what the other side
even CNN it was CNN and Washington Post
and he's like what did I I posted this
these articles like it was it was a
statement based on this they claimed it
was misinformation in which case that's
a false statement of fact so he should
at least try to Sue and the damages are
that his new book is coming out and
they're shutting down his his means for
promotion this is this is a platform
where people pay to get access to share
information and so if Dave has built a
bit access which creates the content
which drives advertisement to the
platform they I I think it's time people
start firing off these lawsuits saying
you can't do this but they're allowed to
ban anyone at any time he signed that
terms of service but we don't understand
is I'm arguing that
that has to change and it changes with
suing so precedent will be set for
instance Twitter defamed Dave Rubin see
one of the problems they have is that
they could have just said no reason we
banned them for fun and they may start
they do they should they've done to
other people they've they've suspended
people and put no reason at all they
just it says like you've been suspended
for blank with Dave it was
misinformation I I believe it was you
know I don't get sued either but I
believe it was misinformation I could be
wrong and uh Dave could say that's just
factual not true um James O'Keefe is
suing specifically because they claim
good I'm not surprised by that right he
was I mean he's the the master of it
they said he was operating multiple
accounts so he said that's fake that's
that's a lie it's a false statement of
fact and I'm gonna sue you and not and
that was a big mistake because now we
can go for Discovery and get internal
Communications on what they've said
about him and his his his organization
so
Dave shitzu yeah that the the one
question by the way in terms of your
point I think it's a good one when you
say well they they're saying that they
can get rid of you for the legal
language would be any reason or no
reason at all so even if you Sue and you
prove that that you were defamed you
might get some money damages but they
can still likely keep you off the site I
think the issue there is is that what's
called an unethical adhesion contract
like can you sign a deal with a company
that is going to give you the chance to
make tens of millions of dollars where
they can take all of your money and all
of your followers away at any time I
don't I mean I law school was a while
ago but I would have some real questions
about whether you can I would have some
real questions about now that these
sites are growing into serious
businesses whether you can do some of
this junior varsity crap like for no
reason given remove someone from your
platform permanently and take their
entire follower account away that sounds
very questionable I mean that was that's
going back to like the early days of
Facebook when people had 100 friends not
only that but there's there's an
expectation based on the rules they set
so of course they say you can be
terminated for for any reason we reserve
that right but there's still an
expectation that these are the rules you
have to follow and so long as you follow
them you are within bounds of being on
the platform Dave broke no rules yeah
but they don't you don't need to break
rules to get booted off those things
right so so the issue is is it an unfair
contract definitely is it are you are am
I if I said to you Ian you can you can
you can come here and you know do all
this work and then uh uh you know have a
great opportunity and so long as you
don't say a naughty word you're fine and
then one day after you've you've been
working here for a long time I just kick
you out the door and you're like but I
didn't break any rules it doesn't matter
it's my house like a right what is a
right to work state what I mean is
it there there are certain contracts
that are unenforceable right so uh
non-competes in many states I don't know
if you you went to law school you said
yes I did yeah like non-competes are
unenforceable and out of states right
that's my understanding yeah so the
there are contractual terms that are
generally not enforceable
um an open non-compete Clause extending
Beyond a certain short period of time
often is I'd have to look at the case
law but the issue here I think would be
more what's called an adhesion contract
where if you sign a contract with a
player like your camera company when you
when you look at the back of the box of
a piece of Tech equipment that in the
terms and conditions go on for 16
printed out pages in a couple situations
I've seen and at the end you check your
X and you submit if that contract were
to include something like if this piece
of equipment breaks you owe us a
thousand dollars or something completely
ridiculous that wouldn't be enforceable
because it would be understood that
that's nonsense that the person with
more power put into the text of the deal
like that would be dispute is very
unsympathetic and I think think I don't
know I actually think your Point's a
really good point but I I think social
media
my actual reaction is come on bro it
can't work that way like even with me at
like 40 000 plus maybe like 20 000 on
different other platforms like
that's I've been absolutely my books
have made bestseller lists like it if
you were just to say okay we're gonna
take these 60 000 people away and we're
gonna set up some kind of permanent ban
so that you I mean I could or you could
easily but the average citizen couldn't
get back on the platform that's just
total BS like it's it's you having the
power position in the contract doing
something that's probably illegal so
like I couldn't sign a contract with you
like Tim couldn't sign a contract that
says if you want to work here and be say
a video engineer I get to punch you in
the face twice a day because it would be
a manipulative use of power I got a
better example I couldn't say Ian you
can come work on the show and to work on
the show you obviously have to be in the
house and I can evict you from the
property without notice at any time
that's actually against the law right so
when it comes it literally is it is
because there's a there's a separate law
that regulates eviction in every state
not to jump in that that's actually a
solid point and that that actually kind
of gets to the point here like are there
other laws for example that protect
protect against say undue deprivation of
income is a claim you might be able to
bring like if a company just says
like any company could do this like I
just got a fairly new vehicle could
Mercedes or BMW say something like if
you miss one payment on your car loan or
better yet if you miss one maintenance
trip for your vehicle we take the
vehicle back can you just say any kind
of ridiculous thing in a contract when
you're selling a product someone else
really needs and not not often no not
only that but typically repossessions
are forfeiture so if you have a car and
you don't pay your your loan payment for
two months they may say we're going to
move to repossess the car because you're
delinquent typically it's not usually
two months you can actually just tell
the repo guy it's my car you can't take
it I'm challenging this as a civil
dispute and they can't take it a lot of
people don't know that so the repo guy
shows up and they go okay and they're
because you got it and that's that's the
game they play in fact you can just call
the police and say I'm in a civil
dispute you can't take my property and
they'll say that's right you can't
so in this instance I wonder if you know
you mentioned about undue deprivation of
income I think the eviction thing is is
an interesting point there may be laws
that people haven't haven't looked at or
realized that you're entering into an
agreement that grants you some kind of
access to a system so it's it's almost
like at the very least
we created laws to protect tenants for a
reason and maybe we can view social
media accounts as us as tenants on a
platform we are using it to run a
business considering a lot of the
economy is now digital especially with
the way YouTube does Super chats and the
way people run their business on these
digital platforms we are effectively
tenants of these these platforms and we
have a contractual agreement but they
can evict us without notice immediately
hey man when you have a business or a
house who at least get 30 days and you
can file a suit to argue why they can't
do this to you now Dave Rubin can can be
on this platform creating entertaining
content and informative content that
builds up an audience on the platform
that makes them money
providing a service to them and then
without notice without due process they
kick them off for a false reason and to
fame him in the process imagine if your
landlord came to your house and you you
had a pizza shop and they put up a big
sign saying this pizza shop puts dookie
in their pizza and then called the cops
and the cops came and kick you out we
got to remove defamation just for the
argument's sake because they can remove
you for no reason so and I think that's
worse I'm saying specifically in the
case of Dave Rubin equate it to if Dave
was running his business in a physical
location he'd have legal protection one
day they just evicted him without notice
one day Dave walks to his pizza shop and
he shows up and the building's empty and
all of his stuff is out in the street
soaking wet in the rain or they would
keep the stuff I mean the stuff you make
it that in their job is YouTube's
content I mean as far as I know yep the
videos this is YouTube's video right now
or better better yet better yet Dave
walks one day to his pizza place to open
up but you know he's got to get there at
9am because they open up for the early
lunch and all of his equipment has been
crushed and mutilated and destroyed and
it's a permanent destruction of
everything he's built and everything of
value because Twitter followers and
accounts do have a market value it's
been calculated by companies companies
pay money for the equivalent of reach
and they say to him the lease said we
can do whatever we want we have laws
saying you can't do that for obvious
reasons because this would it's
disruptive to the economy as we're
moving into a digital economy how can we
have that people build their business on
YouTube monkey Jones deserves a shout
out whenever this happens monkey broke
no rules monkey made monkey Jones had a
channel he had 300 something thousand
subscribers it was his business it was
his life he dedicated years to building
that business and he broke no rules he
was given no warning and everything was
destroyed overnight at the very least I
understand the argument they say in
their contract they can do it well
certainly there should be a law saying
they can't because it's un it's it's
undue deprivation and it's eviction we
need a monkey broke no rules shirt
that's a great phrase monkey broke no
rules he broke I don't know anything
about this guy though I'm Googling him
right now he made a lot of really edgy
content and and uh he pushed the
envelope in a way but it was not much he
didn't break the rules those people are
tough as a as an admin those people are
tough to deal with when they when they
get around the rules that's why we put
in Clauses it Minds anyway we can remove
anything at any time because people
would be so snakey with with the rules
to get the most disgusting stuff in
front of people in front of kids it's
crazy so I will say that it's it's
arguable that the content he made was
distasteful to a lot of people but how
about they just say hey guy this one
video you made we're gonna take it down
but then he did it over and over no they
didn't do that they banned him without
even giving a single strike one day all
of a sudden his channel was just gone
and they banned a second Channel which
was like the anime reviews or something
it was brutal wow it was brutal I
understand the strike system I
understand the warning system and if you
see all three plus strikes at once you
ban the account upright instantly got
three seasons this guy back on a bunch
of edge social medias Simeon Jimmy and
doing better yeah okay probably yeah
people are loving this guy from space to
erased my story is monkey Jones
IMDb
so he had uh if Kong loses I'm going to
let's say end it all okay I see the
issues here edgy finally leaking my all
of my DMs okay oh my gosh so he he he
was making edgy content about an
individual I'm not gonna name who's a
Despicable individual and it didn't
break any of their specified rules and
they didn't even just like how about
this here's an email hey
um look we understand you know this is
the kind of you produce here are the
terms we set forward we're asking you
right now
don't do these things otherwise we'll
have to ban you
and he would have said yes the same
thing with with uh with Carl Benjamin I
said this when patreon banned him I was
like Patriot uh patreon banned uh Carl
without warning overnight because of
something he said on a live stream like
a year prior and if they had just gone
to him and said hey we saw that you were
on a stream and you said these things
it causes problems for us because we're
getting a lot of bad press we'd
appreciate if you if you wouldn't do
this Carl would have been like all right
I don't want to lose my patreon so you
know no problem but they didn't they
just nuke his income instantly what do
you think about small websites like if
you started a website that people could
sign into and it had like 500 users that
that you would retain the right to ban
anyone at any time
people who are not using the platform to
run a business or you don't know why but
it's like a small social media right so
so this is the difference between
Twitter being a Convention Center that's
Contracting you to set up a kiosk and a
pizza place having a chair where someone
could sit down to enjoy your pizza so if
I have a website with users and I do hey
go to timcast.com become a member that's
more akin to like me having a pizza shop
and I come in the morning I open the
door and someone comes and sits down in
the diner in the dining room section so
yeah I can throw them out because we
don't have a contractual agreement other
than it's a public accommodation for
them to come now to be fair there is
still a a for websites where you pay
membership there is a bit of an
agreement like you'd have to actually
have a civil dispute over the currency
if someone was paying to be a member and
then you kicked them out when they were
still active members so if you're like a
country club you can get into a dispute
if someone's like I pay to be here and
they throw them out anyway and they say
well you broke the rules you can still
get into those conflicts but I'll say
Twitter is more like McCormick Place you
know McCormick Place right yeah of
course the massive Chicago convention
center right it's public right that's
why I'm pretty sure it's public is that
the merchandise smart yeah well anyone
anyone can book that entire uh area I
mean if you want to hold an event there
it's giant yeah so what it's like 100
200 000 square feet or something yeah
it's the biggest biggest of its kind in
the midwest I think there's an
equivalent in New York maybe it's it's
amazing merchandise
yeah it's on it's on the lake there's
actually two when you go into tunnel you
can go but uh they do a bunch of events
there in car shows if they said you can
come in and set up your business your
your kiosk here to display your product
during this big convention and then you
go in and then this generates ticket
sales for the greater event or uh you
pay you know or something or even if
they let you in for free you're spending
time energy and money to be there
for them to just come and just tear down
and Destroy what you've set up it cost
you money Dave's account it costs him
money to operate I understand it's not
as much as like running an actual brick
and mortar shop but a lot of people
their Twitter accounts are based on
labor they actually do there have been
people journalists who have been banned
and they actually go on the ground and
they film things there have been
activist accounts that have paid to go
and go on the ground and live stream and
film and they've been banned for this so
these are people who invested hard
currency to be on a platform who are
banned for no reason they were Occupy
Wall Street activists people who do not
like me who I defended they were banned
and they broke no rules we we can't
operate a system like this the problem
is the Democrats will absolutely never
never push forward a law like this
because they're ideologically uh in a
strong position with their ideologues
controlling these things and Republicans
won't do it because Republicans are
worthless morons I'm very like
laissez-faire about this kind of stuff I
don't like the government imposing laws
under corporations about how they have
to run their business but I'm also very
um against monopolies and I think
they've kind of monopolized the social
media I wonder what you think about this
idea that once a social network gets
large enough we've free their software
code via law you know we break up the
Monopoly of their code so other people
can spin up like another YouTube that
can Co interoperate with other YouTube
so you can subscribe to YouTube on their
main users on the main account but you
can create your own terms of service on
your site so it will create the
marketplace of ideas for
terms of service basically it'll it'll
create the the market will be not who
has the best technology it'll be who has
the best terms but Ian that's like
saying if the city comes and destroys
your your business with a with a
wrecking ball you can just go and build
another building somewhere else can you
can you afford physical property can you
afford it it doesn't cost anything I
mean it doesn't really cost you don't
have to build things it's just to like
chip it because I mean you guys are both
making excellent points but in terms of
what you said I I think the solution
there is probably a little off in terms
of we're going to free the source code
so anyone can know how to for example
build these kind of sites I mean I think
most of the table is competent enough
with tech to at least retain someone to
do I mean you had parlor for example
yeah but it's nowhere near as effective
as Facebook if you look at their site
functionality they have like Marketplace
they have like dating sites they have an
amazing message
algorithms yeah but I mean parlors
direct competitor was Twitter I'd say
parlor is about 90 is good and they're a
lot Freer I mean Twitter only has one
like or respond function still to this
date on tweets you can't edit tweets the
issue with parlor wasn't that their Tech
code was a little bit worse it was that
they were destroyed by a corporate
monopolists I mean after they were
falsely accused of being responsible for
the the capital rioting and there's no
lies from the media we now know yeah we
now know that explicitly that was
coordinated primarily through Facebook
which is a more Boomer piece attack in
the first place I'm not surprised by
that at all but I mean parlor was
immediately the scapegoat like it can't
be the big two it can't be the big two I
think some messaging went out and so I
mean you saw this incredible stuff like
what is it Amazon online whatever their
AWS yeah aw Amazon web services Amazon
web services servers yeah but I mean
their actual ability to run a website at
the basic level of working with the
server working with the provider at the
top level was taken away I mean they
they were taking off the app stores and
it turns out they're only two or three
of those two in fact so I mean that's
what destroyed parlor and I think that
that gets back to a a bigger issue here
which is
I totally respect your point I'm very
libertarian in a lot of issues when you
say I don't like the government
interfering with big Tech sure the issue
comes up when you're dealing with
businesses that are nearly as powerful
as the government I mean and this is
true even outside of tech if you ask
someone whether they wanted to be the
CEO of Disney or the governor of Montana
no power seeking person would say I
would want to be the governor of Montana
these Fortune 500 companies are
extraordinarily powerful players and
when you get into Tech where you get
into the literal control of speech I
mean you see that Facebook Twitter these
kind of Google have more control over
speech what we see and now what we can
say than really anyone else in the game
uh certainly they have more influence
than most state-level governments in the
USA so kind of getting to the point I
mean like if we say we don't want the
government to regulate the tech boys
and they're only four or five people
that are actually in charge of these
tech companies and they're racing each
other to Mars and home built Rockets
these guys are not going to just decide
to regulate their business the state at
some level I like legislation to be as
simple as possible but for the state to
come in and say
due to the fact that this probably
violates other well-known laws against
for example adhesion you can't simply
terminate accounts for any reason or no
reason at all just as you can't fire
people because of their Race For example
they're copy it's like this all
throughout the law I I wouldn't have a
problem with that I think for right now
though legally you might be correct it's
up in the air between us it's positioned
the ball is probably somewhere between
what we're saying can you do that I
think his point was just you shouldn't
be able to if people are going to
pressure Congress that's the thing right
my argument is that we need to make laws
to enforce this we need to make laws to
definitively State it however there's
also a path towards filing lawsuits and
making the correct arguments so one of
the problems is I hear from
conservatives all the time that you
can't sue for X you can't sue for y and
I'm like you can you just need to make a
good argument and then get it before a
judge and then see if they agree with
you because like the reality is I've
seen judges have really awful rulings
I've seen judges have rulings where like
all of legal Twitter was like what was
he thinking this ruling but the judge
said it so here's what you do
there's got to be I've seen some
lawsuits pertaining to like defamation
and Bannings and I'm like what were
these lawyers thinking these lawyers
don't know anything about the platform
and they don't know how to make an
argument to a judge about this this is
the issue uh I don't want to say
something as simple as Boomers don't get
Tech but I I assume all of you I assume
you guys give an interest range watched
the set of hearings on the internet
probably four or five years back where
people are saying things like it's a
series of tubes oh yeah of course yeah
you got that information packed into
them pipes there you know so like the
cloud I'll tell you my favorite thing
I've ever heard when I was working in
live streaming I was doing developing
mobile app mobile apps and I was at a
conference with a bunch of like well-off
individuals and I was talking about how
we're trying to build an app where we
can do these these photos you know we do
live streaming and the wind goes the
cloud
and I was like yeah yes and she goes the
cloud and I was like
sure what about it she goes why don't
you use the cloud and I was like I'm I'm
not sure I understand what you mean
she's like use the cloud it's like have
you considered that and I'm like are you
saying that we should have servers like
do you I'm do you know what the cloud
means she didn't something it might be
posted remotely I mean novel stuff we're
gonna have a data center I'm like what
you had no idea which um and she thought
she was had this profound idea about
what the CL I'm like the cloud isn't a
new thing it's a it's like a buzz term
it's like a branding word it just means
like hosting your site like in a data
center we're gonna build gaseous servers
that are like you spray chemicals into
the air and that's gonna host your data
and then you'll fire lasers through it
to access the data and it'll actually be
Cloud Crystal because lasers can
solidify gas you can then pack that data
into the tubes and you can get it to the
internet to Mars and back yeah it's
really it's good stuff I mean but yeah
this this is all funny but actually this
ties into something that we really do
look look at in political science which
is the extremely Advanced age being
polite for the medium of politicians so
like when people are talking about a
situation like the 78 year old Joe Biden
if I have that correct run against like
the 74 year old Trump and people are
saying things like Trump is five years
younger he's much more vigorous he's
ready to go he was spry that's true I
mean you know I'm I'm pretty sure that
if you're running for president in the
United States there are people you know
following you around spritzing you with
Virgin blood and grinding up five
Adderall into your banana smoothie
hypothetically but I mean like so the my
only comment with this is the issue with
a lot of this is that the typical what
is circuit court level maybe District
Court level federal judge doesn't know a
whole hell of a lot about the
complexities of the internet so people
tend to resort to heuristics in times
like that like yep I I don't like
messing with the man's private business
but the reality is that if we want to
prevent something like there's no reason
Twitter couldn't shut down the
Republican Party
they took an active sitting president of
the United States people forget how
crazy this is because we're focusing so
much on the media which leans 93 left or
left and left leaning moderates focus on
like one six immediately following what
was a embarrassing graphic series of
incident social media worked together to
ban the sitting president from every
major social media platform he's not on
Facebook he's not on Twitter I think
YouTube may have restored some content
but I mean like I was actually talking
to a female friend of mine and she was
like I was at what's the expensive bike
Peloton I was at the Peloton gym and you
can't search Trump on Peloton like if
you're messaging The Other Women in the
gym there are words you can't use like
Maga you know KAG I'm not going to get
into some of the other stuff about the
election but you can't refer to Trump on
Twitter and like the Ivanka and Melania
accounts on Peloton I have not verified
this myself but we're gone like these
aren't things you can see on the social
portion of Peloton I assume that's true
but I mean I know it's true for
Pinterest for example the man vanished
he was non-personed and anyone can be
non-personed in this fashion there's
nothing to prevent a conservative
billionaire assuming they're already in
this field from taking down the
Democrats are certainly the greens and
there's nothing to prevent the more
prevalent leftist Tech Bros from saying
the Republican party is responsible for
three incidents of vaguely defined hate
speech they're gone the question is
whether they should be able to do that
and I think the consensus here we're
having an interesting moral and almost
semantic debate but I think the
consensus kind of has to be no well my
question though is How would would you
let the government dictate what
corporations have to make their terms of
service like would you let the
government write the terms of service
well hell no because they don't know
what they're doing actually I think that
sorry it all but finish please I don't
want to bust in there and then I guess
if you can you answered that but the
follow-up would be like at what level do
you command that a social network is
allowed to ban people and that has to
stop Banning people for what what and
how do you define what hate speech means
How does it go down just crime I
wouldn't get into any of that actually I
think I think Tim you and I might be on
the same page just quickly from my end
one I think law works best when it's
extremely short and clear so I would
simply say that adhesion contracts are
illegal in the context of social media
boom solved 70 of it and then I would
say like
for example actually kind of I teach a
con Law class at KSU and there already
are exceptions to the rule of free
speech you guys might correct me if I
miss one but I mean there's obviously
pornography involving inappropriately
young people or non-human subjects you
know keeping it virtuous for social
media but uh yeah you know
no no sheep or boys I mean that's an
exception generally although we're for
whatever reason relaxing on sheep here
in the USA
um but no open fraud no lies for more
than 500 or whatever it is state by
state ever no libel no slander that's
actually your point about well that's
that's civil tort right yeah that civil
tort but okay yeah not criminally banned
but still enforced I think it would be
reasonable to put that level of civil
tort in it we're talking about the same
sort of thing and then uh direct
incitement to Serious violence those
would be the exceptions to free speech
three criminal one civil I would have no
problem with saying
social media can block that content but
nothing else well what about spam
I mean that how do you define exactly
how do you define it you just that's
what you block people you don't like
yeah yeah but it can destroy it or you
can destroy networks if you keep
spamming a DDOS attack is different from
just Spam but you can still destroy
Network and you can make an argument
about if something's disorderly conduct
harassment or assault actually a DDOS
attack would be illegal in the majority
of US states right like that's getting
into the actual sort of hacking hacking
is a term I hate but it's getting into
that space like cyber work yeah Cyber
attack if somebody keeps posting the
same message it would be akin to if
someone kept mailing you a letter every
single day yeah you'd go to your postal
carrier and say stop delivering these to
me throw them in the trash and then you
get a bunch of accounts and then if they
can't preemptively ban those then you
have harassment and so if harassment is
actually no if one person's spamming you
and then they spam will and they spam me
and they spam Lydia we all block them
they keep spanning new people that's
when the site will step in and ban those
people so it's illegal no that's legal
to do no it is I can it's right on the
line guys actually as some legal
background points on both sides but I
mean I think okay add that to the terms
like I really do think as a
aggressive and somewhat a moral leader
in Practical life if it comes to like
what's ksu's recruitment plan gonna be
for this year not that would be my
decision or like how am I going to run
my business which I do do pretty
successfully I mean I think a lot of
this stuff can be settled like you get
The Tech Guys and you get four or five
congressmen in the north talking about
in the back room and you say okay these
six things you can ban it will and will
allow you what about porn
that actually
um I would personally allow legal porn
but I think that
to some extent it wouldn't be very
difficult to do this like I understand
what you're asking like there's there's
some technical on the fence questions
but I mean what you would simply say is
one no adhesion contracts where people
can be banned for no reason this is your
major point right now there's an
adhesion contract where people can be
banned for no reason and then you would
say social media providers all right I
mean to something just
but social media providers are allowed
to ban all content that is civilly or
criminally against the law oh and here's
how porn would work or that is civilly
or criminally that it is civilly or
criminally legal to restrict for an
audience of people under 18 or under 21
since those individuals use social media
insights what about violence violence is
fine it doesn't fall in those categories
it's like R-rated so it's seven eighteen
then you can say the same thing parents
responsibility can they ban someone for
putting a video up of a bully fight like
do they let 13 year olds wander them by
themselves downtown in this this isn't
about that this is about internet video
I'm talking about and who dictates what
they can and can't yes put on my point
is we wouldn't let 13 year olds walk
into an adult video store
well it's not allowed yeah I think that
there are also a couple of different
questions here one of the deepest ones
since we're all in getting to that Dad
range is like should 13 year olds be on
Twitter I mean there's some very
practical oh no there's some very
practical things that you could do to
take away I mean most young men
including me I read recently start
consuming porn in the USA at like 11 or
12. and it actually does no but it has a
really
I mean I had a normal high school sex
life like you you definitely hook up
with real people in life but the
exposure to like extreme edgy spitting
my mouth content worse than 12 and your
girlfriend's 13 is not going to give you
a lot of tips about how to act in real
life so kids to some extent need to be
moved away from a lot of that
um but the Practical question I think
this is something that would be
negotiated among intelligent people
presumably intelligent people If This
Were Ever to happen but I think what you
could say is absolutely no adhesion
contracts as a Baseline and I may be
technically off on that legal term but
no unfair contracts of this kind then we
expect social media to ban content that
is against the law as a violation of
Free Speech but then you got to decide
what state law are you are you working
out of depends on where the corporation
was found a lot of this is federal
criminal law though I mean like a ban on
you know underage or non-human
pornography would be fairly easy to
enforce in the USA and this is what you
want to be at right you want a you
things explicitly banned like Terror
content I don't like the government the
federal government doing it because if
you want to do a video on how to grow
weed like it's legal in California but
not legal federally and then so you
could bust up a corporation for that
Federal makes stupid and the FEDS in
California I co-founded mines are you
familiar with mines.com uh definitely
heard that honestly I don't know you
built it from the ground up base and
this is my life for the last decade is
figuring out how to how to equitably
create terms and I can't figure it out I
don't think the government should do it
for us and I and I don't think people
should be forced into a mold this is why
I go with the free the free software
free the code it doesn't do anything
though but you'll never explain no it
doesn't if you give me the plans to
build the house I can't build a house
bro I don't know
gather that can help you build it how do
I do that how do I pay them I gave you
the I don't care about that I gave you
the blueprint that I I actually I'm very
intelligent babe but I'm kind of with
Tim on this one I mean like when you say
like The Parlor thing we can argue about
whether the setup code the the basic
structure of the website someone was
worse or better than Twitter the fact is
it wasn't allowed to exist and I think
that this will happen to this see this
is the thing when we take these morally
I suppose to the extent I think about
moral questions I agree with you but the
question is if you say corporations are
allowed to handle their own business and
do whatever they want produce whatever
content they want as long as it's legal
they could not knock you off for any
reason or no reason at all the issue
arises when they knock off the sitting
president of the United States or when
they a competitor arises that probably
would have been good enough for Trump
and those guys to jump back on
immediately removed when Laura Loomer
runs for office and they give her a
rival an account which is free access to
advertising and promotion and deny her
one as a candidate I think I agree that
uh about Amazon they have a monopoly
that's very dangerous on servers right
now but when you look at what about the
Parlor Twitter like what's better Tech
okay that's a decent argument but
nothing compares to YouTube and Facebook
they are completely out of the ballpark
phenomenal technology
dude nothing is better than YouTube
technologically you go to the YouTube
Studio you're actually making a monopoly
argument though you're saying that
between Tech and control so a lot of
these things have to have definitions
like do you agree the government should
break up extreme monopolies well you
look at what happened to Standard Oil
rockefeller's company and what they did
was break it into six oil companies
correct Rockefeller took stock in all
six and became more wealthy and Powerful
after the breakup but we we now prohibit
that from the departing senior executive
or the previous senior executive like
there was a response to that but like so
for example one thing you could do is
take Facebook and break Facebook is
itself an agglomeration of different
companies but if you broke off Facebook
Messenger into a new company they still
know how to build it because they still
have the code so they can rebuild it no
but that's what I'm saying like it at
the most basic level I actually want
something more intense than this that
would involve some element of government
regulation we can debate that because
we're free citizens but at the most
basic level Facebook is about five or
six companies I mean like whatever the
ads platform is called Instagram
messenger Facebook ad system so so what
all of these companies do Facebook and
and Google specifically is that Google
obviously is a handful of companies
YouTube is not only a video hosting
platform it is a video distribution
platform it is a marketing platform and
it is an ad sales platform all of these
things or I should say they integrate
the ad sales into you know all of these
things operate this way Google I should
say YouTube specifically isn't ad sales
it's ad delivery content delivery
content storage all of these things in
one if you broke that up YouTube
wouldn't exist it needs those components
to work together YouTube however is not
the best that's an absurd statement
there are many other sites that have
come for with newer technology that's
better and there's a really interesting
phenomenon that happens in technology
why is it that the United States has
really crappy cell networks because we
invented it first so for I think what
was the first Network's ID IDE and
network
um so we create this really crappy cell
network but at the time it was
revolutionary well Korea didn't do cell
networks not even then not even for 10
years then we invented a few different
things we ultimately end up with the
CDMA standard and the GSM standard CDMA
was kind of bad but it was really good
compared to where we were before GSM
comes out that's a global uh you know it
became like a global standard and then
Korea decides we're going to build a
cell network because they were building
it for the first time they built a
really good one yeah because the United
States was just improving the existing
one it was always lagging behind
happening in Africa they're putting
solar panels on houses and bypassing
Central Electric grids exactly there's a
lot of developing Tech in the stable
African States and I think a lot of
people are sleeping on especially giving
Chinese colonization so like that
Chinese Nigerian complex in West Africa
is going to be a rival to the West in 30
years and so I'll stress this right now
Rumble is better than YouTube I gotta
look at Rumble we didn't use I saw I
only started recently publishing to
rumble YouTube has the audience YouTube
YouTube still got the algorithms
algorithms incredible the algorithm
that's it's not it's not relevant that's
the marketing issue of it that's so the
issue here is we're talking about
technology inferring the code it's
pointless we use YouTube because it is a
massive McCormick Center conference room
and I know there's a billion people
hanging out in location location we use
Rumble for a variety of other things
because it's a better service better
technology better bandwidth
customization Nation it's better across
the board even Vimeo is better YouTube
is good because there's a massive room
in this in this broken down ridiculous
building and the security guards are
dicks and it's like yeah but they'll put
up a sign with an arrow pointing to my
building and there's a billion people
got the partner program they've got the
rumble does all that too YouTube Studios
incredible dude
it's it's
pretty good it's amazing Rumble Rumble
I've seen anything remotely even close
what like like YouTube Studio the
ability for a user to go and have their
analytics and their database like their
control files that have all that stuff
you can show me that Rumble is actually
better than that or even hell is a
candle I mean that company's been
pouring billions into that for years for
like a decade and they've got like 50
000 people working on it I will concede
YouTube uh has pretty good analytics but
everything has has an analytics system
it's a big big production to create
stuff like that so then we're getting
more and then into the the marketing
space of things if we're talking about
just a video hosting I no it's the whole
package you can't compete with YouTube a
user that wants to create a job on the
internet another video to do with that
dude it has to do with the fact that
YouTube controls the audience it's the
Monopoly on the the content it's the
Monopoly on the on the code
on the network
people don't use Twitter because Twitter
is good yeah that Twitter is good mine
is way better than Twitter and there's a
reason why less people use it than
Twitter is because everyone's on Twitter
that's that's a difficult thing to
overcome it's not the only reason
Twitter's awesome Twitter's fantastic
I've never had a bug on Twitter have you
I've never I've had frequent bugs on
Twitter I also I have never had you
can't edit tweets I mean in terms of
some of the most basic elements of
interface like I'm not mocking Twitter
Twitter's okay but I don't think that
the reason that Twitter is so utterly
dominant that space is the brilliant
quality of its Tech I don't think if you
took 15 guys from MIT they'd have much
trouble designing something roughly
equivalent or better they're different
elements like if your site completely
sucks if your code sucks if your
engineering guys suck obviously some
people aren't going to use that product
but also like the rumble YouTube debate
you could go either way the reality is
that they're what how many millions of
people are there on YouTube right now
posting video content using it I don't
know billion billions of hours a day or
something I don't know what it is it's
like a billion one I don't know if
that's users or videos about a million
users per month billion billion users
yeah billion one per month that's why
YouTube has that it's got to be more
than a billion because if CNN's getting
100 and fox is getting 200 and then
you've got big YouTubers it's got to be
in the tens of billions per month
reviews you know it is probably unique
uploads yeah there's some unique users
versus views or something but a lot of
this is we're discussing a lot of
technical detail intelligently but at
some level like I mean the point that
YouTube is viewed is better than Rumble
because there are a billion people using
it you know quantity has a quality all
its own I don't think anyone would
dispute that the the real one root
question here that we're chopping around
is should a company that has a billion
users that has allowed you quote unquote
to get to four million users be able to
terminate your account at will not I
think no but I also think that's
probably going to require some new
legislation so that that actually by the
way for like the center right or the
tech sector or whatever you want to call
it that is a legitimate goal not
congressmen sitting around mumbling in
their ancient way trying to describe the
internet but will you add some basic
Clause to the law strengthening the
rules against adhesion contracts or
going back perhaps to more traditional
Monopoly law and again we're kind of
fantasizing here but I don't see any
reason that wouldn't happen
you know except will power from the
Republicans is lacking and Democrats
have the ideological Advantage I'm also
concerned about the the market itself
like you said they have a billion users
or something like how do you how do you
break that up that's that's exactly you
you can't you got to get the code away
it's the only that doesn't make any
sense I can build a YouTube interacts
yeah then why don't you use Rumble
because it I don't know I don't need it
why not because I have YouTube in mind
because YouTube gets you more views and
definitely and I can make fun of the
aura boros here I mean it's obviously
there the tech is great but there's a
reason people use Twitter instead of
parlor then that's probably the weakest
of the examples there's a reason people
use YouTube instead of Rumble and when
people started using parlor they shut
parlor down parlor was facing critical
mass it was exploding in users Tyler was
the number six app across both app
stores parlor was actually outperforming
either Twitter or Facebook I forget
which immediately like the day before it
was shut down and we've seen this by the
way this this is an important point I do
want to make here we've seen the steel
fist come out of the velvet glove a few
times recently like large competitive
countries do have a ruling class that
knows it's a ruling class however many
conspiracies are real and all this sort
of thing so I mean like for example with
um the Robin Hood stuff where people
started playing the short sellers in the
stock market which I was a part of I
think many people were
um but shut it down yeah they
immediately shut it down they came up
with some BS reason like we're running
out of money here boys and immediately
halted trading on the stocks that were
being affected in a way that was hurting
powerful rich people you can call that a
coincidence but you have to combine that
with the same coincidence where a parlor
beats FB one day and the next day it's
like well that's how the capital Riot
was coordinated it wasn't Facebook which
is used by far more older demographic
individuals we needed to get these boys
out of here and so parlor shuts down I
think parlor's back now but but no their
moments was broken yeah right well let's
take super chats and see what the super
chats have to say if you haven't already
give that like button a little tab
become a member at timcast.com we don't
do bonus segments on Fridays but we do
have a vlog coming up tomorrow and we
made Luther burgers and uh I
it's a double bacon cheeseburger with
two glazed donuts instead of buns whoa
put mustard on it and we were like
oh that's the thing that took it over
the line
yeah but it I I we had a minute I had a
small one with no sauce it was just the
cheeseburger no bacon and just the donut
we did one donut it's good yeah I
imagine that oh come on so that's the
Vlog tomorrow it'll be up at like 9am or
whatever youtube.com cast Castle let's
take these super chats
anime audio commentary says did you guys
hear about what Chris Chan did I heard
the leaked audio and it left me
speechless no no I have no idea what
this meme is supposed to be but isn't
Chris Chan that likes skateboarder who's
really good he's like he's got a YouTube
video what are they talking about never
heard of the guy sorry all right but
there's like a meme or something about
what did he do and everyone's like oh
I'm so shocked but there's like nothing
really happening
questionable content says Ian
chiropractors are a scam it is illegal
to call yourself a doctor in Europe if
you are just a chiropractor without any
additional medical degree yeah when you
get your your butt your back cracked
it's up to you to continue to hold your
new posture you can't they're not gonna
fix you and then you go home and go back
to your old lazy posture you you need to
change your own posture so it's you end
up doing 99 of the work the other thing
with Chiropractic I mean like I've gone
to a chiropractor they are great with
the human back I mean it's a very
advanced level of sort of muscular I
don't know it felt like a very intense
massage is a good way to remove some of
that technical jargon but they
definitely they know their way around
the spine my understanding is the
problem of Chiropractic is that they
claim that working on the spine can cure
almost everything if you read the
original manuals for the field it's sort
of like this is how to relax depression
via spine pressure so you get into that
same weird maybe medical Zone that you
do with acupuncture I think yes Skeleton
King 322 says and this is interesting
that fit right in there yeah I can't
share this podcast on Facebook at all
excuse me it might be the title our work
here is done yeah I don't know I don't
know maybe maybe uh just one well no
maybe it's just you Skeleton King maybe
uh everybody should try sharing this
podcast on Facebook right now to see if
Skeleton King is incorrect so uh who
knows I mean you'll have to take the URL
and then paste it onto Facebook and
press enter who knows oh yeah
I strongly encourage people to share
this as widely as possible if you want
to tag me on it on Twitter
um I'm at will underscore duh underscore
b-e-a-s-t-630 so let's see if it works
right on Pierce warsick says hey Tim
update uh from my grocery store all
employees are required to wear masks
starting Monday school just mandated
student wear masks even after acquiring
vaccination yeah the New York Times had
an article saying that I think it's um
what was it Broadway is going to require
vaccines and masks did you say at the
beginning of the show that these
articles are saying that people with the
vaccine are are not less contagious the
New York Times said people with the
people vaccinated people have the same
likely likeliness to spread covid as
people who are unvaccinated however
however they the context they left out
to make everyone angry is that they're
less likely to catch coven meaning show
symptoms they're 94 less likely to get
coveted that's I mean that that's a good
summary but that's the issue like x89 to
90. except that the problem with that
data is in Massachusetts there was an
outbreak where 75 percent of those who
got sick were vaccinated and the
vaccination rate in Massachusetts is
63.9 meaning it was disproportionately
those who were vaccinated who got sick I
don't have explanations for this nor am
I starting anything other than we need
to figure out why that happened
so look the New York Times said
you are less likely to get it but you if
you do you are equally likely to spread
it the one the one thing I would say
here is and I am also not asserting or
making any medical claims but the the
one thing that I would say here is like
most of the research on the vaccine I
that's a fascinating story I don't know
if that's an outlier situation like you
would find outliers in any pool of you
know 200 million I do think that's
important to note but all of the stuff
the CDC Israeli had set research on the
vaccine kind of puts the efficacy at
between 89 and 94 that I have personally
read
um it may be a little less for Delta say
you know one in ten but to have a
breakthrough infection that's
transmissible you do need to have a
breakthrough infection so a lot of this
just seems like panicking once again
like we've got seniors reasonably well
protected the average covet victim in
the USA was 81 as I recall they want
lockdowns that's correct there's or I
don't know if there's a unified they
there but it's easy just if you're in a
position of political leadership and
you're a bit weak-minded it's easy to
just say not one like life we're going
with the most extreme thing we tried
before here it goes again in my opinion
so the question last one sentence
question here but the question is okay
you've been vaccinated say you're 85
percent less likely to get coveted which
puts your risk of getting and
transmitting fatal covet about on par
with the flu the only people you could
give this to at the normal pre-existing
risk would be unvaccinated people mostly
younger who've chosen not to get the
shot for personal health reasons so I
don't see any moral liability here I
don't think it's the vaccinated that are
filling up the hospitals to the extent
anyone is I haven't seen any data
showing that hospitals are overloaded
for quite a while on this yeah it seems
like the same arguments keep coming up
like just you know 15 months to flatten
the curve kind of stuff all right
Zenovia says Tim even though Civics
can't be charged using the UCMJ they're
already calling the others extremists
once done well I will never forget when
Obama had a U.S citizen executed by
drone
um Zenovia what do you mean a U.S
citizen wasn't it four
I can at least cite Anwar al-alaki and
Abdul Rahman al-alalaki and I'm pretty
sure there were a couple others but I
could be wrong
all right Jared The Lifeguard says
listen to the podcast while digging up
my potato plants by hand Barefoot in the
garden it feels great to get filthy and
intimate with Mother Nature so we had uh
so our garden is basically we're done
with it we are we're just waiting now on
the sunflower seeds but everything else
basically has been harvested and we're
over it but uh the chickens went in
because we have a um we have one long I
guess we call it like planter I guess
you call it and we had the jalapenos
have been picked the plants are all done
the chilies are gone we we had basil
basil bushes though which are amazing
like each and every one of those leaves
just basil amazing the chickens they
found it and they started uprooting the
plants and like you know doing the dirt
baths so we had to we took the basil out
we we repotted it and moved it and then
we planted some more tomatoes and now
we're going to do like a separate
smaller individual potted garden and
then we're gonna we're actually
cementing over and we're gonna move the
garden over but yeah it's good fun the
chickens have decided they're going to
destroy everything as they do and they
yell while they're doing it
all right Arc Arch Smith says republics
function as the battle between oligarchs
less the Roman Republic more the
Renaissance republics of Italy shout out
to Ian read up on the Medici and others
like him
the Medici there you go
Maris McMullen says I'm a wood turner
and make cremation urns I found less
than five companies that do the same in
the US it hurts me that so many are
willing to buy such a Sentimental item
made with slave labor instead of
American hens yeah what does America
even make anymore we've we've offshored
everything you know even our cremation
earns we still make weapons Haas that's
true yeah that's true good at that
Matthew Houck says Australia lost a war
with birds expectation they could even
remotely fight their nearly disarmed
masses as laughable when are you going
to have Thomas sowalon I would love it
yeah whenever he wants loved to yeah
Larry Elder too that'd be fantastic
all right let's see 2020 Mana says I'm
currently moving to West Virginia I just
decided to get in my car and head that
way no real plan if you all know anybody
looking for a welder please shout them
out I own my own machine cool very cool
uh West Virginia is fantastic I love the
wine berries man we we had wineberry
season they're gone now they're all
withered but man for those that month or
two where there was just red berries
everywhere and we just took them all and
it was great we made ice cream and cake
with it that's awesome you walk in the
backyard and there's just hundreds
pawpaw is coming up though we're gonna
make some pawpaw cake that's I'm excited
for that hillbilly banana no West
Virginia man that's what I'm talking
about
all right let's see
Jonathan Duggar says of the 998 million
monthly views that CNN got how many of
them are people dumping all over them
like 80 is it like it's like 80 do they
measure it we're like at seven o'clock
they measure 700 000 views and eight
o'clock they measure 800 000 views but
it's just 700 of the same people 700
yeah yeah and then they'll be like there
was 15 000 views but it was like dude
just because you divided the show into
two one two one hour segments doesn't
mean that those 800 000 people watched
it twice
well it it depends on for the uh The
Advertiser so it would count as two
that's a weird way to count metrics this
is the same thing with tech Brands using
page views right which is why you scroll
through these 15 and 20 Page lists of
celebrities like if you're even mildly
unscrupulous with views like every one
of those is a person clicking on a
unique page of your site I mean so
that's does that mean you have 15 unique
observers of that poll no yeah so uh if
I can mention that live viewership on
this show is not displayed on YouTube
but they only display what's called VOD
viewership and so our live viewership
tends to be a couple hundred thousand
views every night it was a lot higher
during election season views are way
down for everybody not just CNN I mean
it's not for us too but we're we're
we're doing all right and that's that's
not displayed if I wanted to play you
know number games we my show uh both my
shows across the board it's easily like
two million views per day you know and
then I can look at CNN and be like what
is Don Lemon getting 170 I mean in
reality
he's really getting that low now it's
hard to actually do a cross between like
okay so I put up how many videos per day
it's kind of a lot you know we have like
five four segments on timcast IRL from
the previous show plus the show then
we've got three from timcast plus we've
got the timcast.com stuff
they're different people but not all
people watch every single part of it but
I will say yeah we are crushing CNN in
terms of that kind of viewership and
another thing about CNN is when you look
at their videos on YouTube it's all
thumbs down people are forced to watch
it and they hate it
all right let's see ask dummy says one
last try internet attention addiction
for all its good now main threat covered
lockdowns riots cancel culture sedentary
life are consequences of this
Consciousness redefining drug web please
have Nicholas Carr to talk Neuroscience
of internet addiction that would be
interesting yes awesome
Thomas Williams says I'm a rural
American 5050 City now bet 50 bucks you
don't care about what uh care about what
US Norms think I'll come on your show
I'm no one I'm just some guy who was
pissed off that I care about politics
now we're trying to figure out how to do
a show like that the challenge is legal
liability for bringing out lots of
people to a non-public space this is
what we run into we're trying to do
events we're trying to do public events
but there's questions about inviting
large groups of people on ticket sales
to a private residence like
we gotta figure it out we got to figure
it out I think we're gonna figure it out
and I think we're we're getting really
close to actually having the events and
I apologize to everybody who's been
waiting but it's like we're just we hit
we hit roadblocks you can't just do
things the government regulates you know
what I mean
all right Steve and Marina degrosa says
New Yorker stuck here in communist
Australia the problem is less the
government and more the sad Aussie
citizens calling the police on their
neighbors I can't wait to come home and
move to Houston Texas it's a good place
man it's a good place
all right
let's see what we got
mrm says Tim heard from family friends
that my Catholic Church diocese is
requiring priests to get the job and if
they don't comply they are to retire
wow
leave it to leave it till then oh leave
it to Ethan haha anyone else get called
an idiot by multiple doctors and nurses
for wearing a mask in January March just
to watch them all change and mask up
#trust that is a very difficult
situation man
all right let's see
um
what do we got here
um gotta be careful
there's a lot of super chats where
people are getting kind of angry so I'm
gonna be careful so I'm Gonna Keep I'm
gonna keep reading
oh oh oh I definitely have to read this
the Laughing Man says I thought what I
do was I'd pretend I was one of those
deaf mutes anybody get that reference no
no uh you know the Laughing Man
and you teach cyber security
I mean you gotta Watch Ghost in the
Shell Standalone complex I'll uh I'll
check it out it's great uh The Laughing
Man was a hacker who in in Ghost in the
Shell people left cyberized brains like
nanites and he actually could hack
people's eyes their brains in real time
so they only saw this like icon of like
this like very rudimentary baseball hat
and there were words from Catcher in the
Rye I thought what I'd do I was I would
pretend what I would pretend I was one
of those death mutes rotating around it
yeah super cool we're more focused on uh
the reality but the movie sounds cool
I'll check it out it's a TV show uh it's
there's a movie and then they made an
anime series but it's it's it's really
cool
all right let's see Trek God says
regarding 230 how about this if a
private company gets special public
protections rights then said companies
should be held to public not private
standards like government cannot curtail
Free Speech as a public standard I mean
that's interesting they're getting
special legal protections from the
government then they should also have in
turn special legal uh guarantees to the
public it's it's a fine line of when the
government takes over and starts to
control that business that's very
dangerous too I I agree with that but I
will say there's actually a very
specific point here that I'm sure both
of you guys have seen in online debates
which is the publisher platform debate
which is becoming more sophisticated so
I mean generally the idea is you can't
regulate a platform you can't punish the
phone company because people discuss
drugs on T-Mobile's lines or something
like that but if you're a publisher if
you remove or edit more than x percent
of the content posted to your site you
can be regulated pretty intensely and I
mean any of those Provisions focusing on
adhesion so on would become more potent
so I mean I think it's the most basic
one sentence level it's pretty obvious
to say Facebook is a publisher yeah when
they do like site-wide notifications or
when they say this is fake news con when
they put like qualifications on content
that's Facebook editorializing and even
a good point and even be even before the
CDC thing which is wild I mean one of
the uh one of the entities that was
flagged as being very unreliable on
kovid was the official Science Academy
of Sweden because Sweden never shut down
and did better than many if not most
other major countries they they did how
dare they but I mean I I think that they
did the things that you would really
want to focus on I mean attempting to
protect seniors avoiding large events I
mean they're very specific it's like
open now there's like videos coming out
people are just walking around minding
yes it's fine and they're they never I
mean they had a lower death per capita
rate than we did it was just always the
elephant in the room that was just
universally ignored but part of that was
Facebook not letting their scientific
agencies communicate information on the
platform all right Xander Klein says the
fact you used a pizza restaurant instead
of a sandwich shop for Dave Rubin for
shame more puns that's a really good
idea Dave let's open a restaurant called
Reuben's Rubens yes I love ribos yeah
they're good yeah good Reuben Reuben's
Rubens Dave what are you doing
all right all right enough jokes all
right let's see we got
phobes or phobus says competition and
decentralization is the answer to Big
Tech censorship increase State
involvement will not turn out the way
people think it will but the problem I
see with a lot of Libertarians is they
don't understand negative rights versus
positive rights we're not saying the
government has to go in and enforce that
a company does something we're saying a
company can't do a thing so maybe that's
not maybe that's not not a good enough
distinction in that I suppose because
then you're arguing they do have to
allow certain content to exist which is
still them doing something I guess now I
don't know look I think you look at what
happens with privately owned public
spaces they say it's owned by a private
business but they gain some tax benefit
there's so there's like instances where
they say if you want to have this
building you have to dedicate x amount
of space to the public so it'll be
privately owned but the public gets to
use it because they let the public use
it they now have one that they have to
guarantee the First Amendment so I don't
see why there's any difference with with
social media
all right what's this
cold will says news voice got nuked this
week I don't know what that is there's
no news on it ironically who is lookup
States the domain status is prohibited
from transferring to another register
key but the good work I'm not familiar
with news voice
all right we're gonna get the big the
big jump in super chats
xenovia X says second Super Chat for the
day Ian check out the YouTube channel
science and futurism with Isaac Arthur
he goes over stuff like space
colonization using current Tech and
graphene et cetera P.S I got chickens
Because of You Tim LOL chickens are
amazing we in the new Vlog it's like we
put a chick we put a camera on the
ground and the chickens walk up to
investigate it oh I love them and it's
really fun it's just like making weird
noises yeah that's great chickens are
chickens are hilarious thanks for
sending me that science science of
futurism thank you
all right let's see Lord Hypno says Tim
you mentioned both your brother and
Rusty Cage in yesterday's podcast and
Mom Keith Jones tonight you should just
go ahead and Shout Shout out the trash
rats podcast they do all three together
shout out to the trash rats podcast I've
not actually uh listened to it but
obviously I know who these gentlemen are
as they are uh um prolific individuals
they're they're of great production and
and uh edginess
all right let's see wait what is this
the this wheel fish says you can share
the link but it does not go to the top
of the news feed it's more than 20 posts
down but at the top of my profile page
interesting weird well we have to have
this experiment everybody just share the
link to the show to see if what this
wheel fish is saying is true hmm
oh man all right let's see Skelly Skelly
wag Swagger says Ian doesn't seem to
understand how open source code Works
Linux for example only ever worked
because the original Source was well
documented big Tech isn't going to
document if forced to go open well then
that's a federal offense
you're saying that they were forced to
hire people to to Archive and document
if yeah if they released code what they
obfuscated the release that would that's
not what he's saying he's saying that
they were documenting Linux that you're
saying that Facebook would be forced to
hire an archivist to like
yeah welcome to the 21st century we need
to understand that code inside we're
saying you don't want the government to
get involved and now you're saying
they're you're starting to break up
monopolies that's what I like to use the
government for that's my biggest whoa
okay well that's that's actually what we
were all kind of arguing about earlier
just how to do it is the yeah Iceman
says have you thought about inviting
Aaron Lewis on the show I mean
they're they're Aaron Lewis rock star
celebrity like of course I'd love to
have someone like Aaron Lewis in the
show I've never thought about it because
I don't know maybe we should try and
reach out to some of these people there
have been some um famous musicians that
we've been in communication with but I'd
love to have Aaron Lewis on the show
that'd be fantastic all right Lost Cause
says Tim a local place does a grilled
cheeseburger where the top and bottom
bun is a grilled cheese
to do that dude we're legit doing that
tomorrow two grilled cheeses with
cheeseburger in the middle
so good but not good not healthy but
good no no not only are we gonna do a
grilled cheese cheeseburger but you know
what the biggest mistake people make
when they make grilled cheese they take
the bread they put the cheese in the
metal they butter both sides and they
Grill on both sides no no no no you
butter the bread Grill it then you take
it off and put the cheese on the grilled
side then close it then butter Grill
both sides of the bread oh
snap did I think I think we will do that
tomorrow that sounds amazing we'll have
to go to the store and buy some stuff
but fun with that sounds helping us
that'll be very very funny all right
we'll just do a a couple more here
X Runner 55 says one of your best guests
this engineer worked with plenty of
political scientists in government and
not of this caliber he knows his stuff
yeah this has been really great actually
I enjoyed talking I hope you come back
this is really fun I'm done you got the
knowledge man that's true yeah this is
sort of my uh my short form visit here
actually uh today I'd be down to come
back absolutely I don't want to make a
grilled cheese yeah I'm pretty cool guy
yeah all right
Ryan Schroeder says I own a Papa John's
in East Aurora Illinois what a special
week to have both Mr Riley and Mr
Schnatter on the show thanks Tim cast
crew for all you do next time you're in
town Mr Riley Pizza on me Papa John's
that's cool next time I'm back I'll I'll
definitely uh check out some of the
local Cuisine Papa John's in East Aurora
man yeah Chris that'd be an interesting
job running a pizza place in East Aurora
let's place a dramatically gentrified
yeah Christopher Noel says Ian Tech and
culture are Downstream from environment
and perception also Will's unintentional
Mike wire mustache was the best drinking
game thanks well because the wire right
there I guess people can see the camera
like it looks like I don't know what
that means like when do you drink
probably when I I have a mustache it's
like the ironic hipster mustache tattoo
on their thumbs love it all right Joe
Darman says Tim you need to watch
Babylon five if you liked DS9 you would
love it Ian is like a car if a car did a
ton of drugs nice it has some Eerie
parallels okay I love that character all
right all right let's just grab uh we'll
just grab uh one more
Larry Funk says they lied about Dave for
the sake of making themselves look like
the good guys which is of value to them
they gained that value at his expense
but I think the problem is uh
it's it's getting to the point where the
narrative is destabilizing you know how
are they gonna how do they keep
maintaining this lie that people broke
the rules when you have someone like
Dave Rubin nearly a million followers
you know is a prominent guy they're
flying too close to the Sun and I think
the narrative is is is is is crumbling
but my friends thank you all so much for
hanging out in this wonderful Friday
night check out that Vlog tomorrow at
youtube.com cast castle and you can
follow this show at timcast IRL on
Facebook Instagram and at timcast
underscore IRL if you're on Tick Tock
for some reason we're there too and you
can follow me personally at timcast uh
go to timcast.com become a member don't
forget we have tons of articles that go
up all the time and your membership
supports those articles gets you ad free
and our whole library of members only
podcasts my friends you can go to the
site now
you can search type in a name and see
the episodes we had with these
individuals so it's very easy to
navigate now and you can see the whole
library of content if you're a member
you want to shout anything out with uh
shout anything out Wilfred
um shout out to Kentucky State
University shout out to those uh
listening to me if any of you want to
hear any more of my drivel going forward
I'm just Wilfred Riley uh wlf r e d r e
i l l y
um check me out you'll find my Facebook
Twitter
websites with my content Etc and shout
out to you guys for having me on the
show enjoyed it absolutely dude thanks
for calling that was really great man um
you guys follow me Ian crossland.net and
at Ian crosson if you wonder what this
shirt is that I'm wearing check it out
yeah whoa this is a uh is exertus that's
Andreas he's actually in the Vlog you
know Andreas and he eats the Luther
Burger yeah he's the wild one and uh you
can pick this shirt up unfortunately I
didn't ask him where beforehand do you
know where he's selling these shirts no
I'll let you know on next week and you
can pick one up of your own at exertus
very exciting you guys are more than
welcome to follow me on Twitter at Sour
Patch Kids as I attempt to gain more
followers and Sour Patch Kids it's a
lofty goal but I think I can make it
because I'm introducing my little cat
tomorrow I'm adopting him officially
tomorrow his name is dip I'm buying the
dip he's a little crackhead super
excited he's gonna be great I'm stoked
so join me over on Twitter we will see
you all tomorrow at 9am at youtube.com
cast Castle thanks for hanging out and
uh we'll see you next time